ça commence bien on verra après
nous
on verra après merci y en a qu'un c'est
parfait en plus il s'intéresse au
vice-président de la commission
extraordinaire
bien eh bien nous allons pouvoir
commencer notre audition qui va clôturer
un peu un cycle du mois de septembre qui
était intense et qui nous a tous
mobilisés pendant des dizaines et des
dizaines d'heures mais des auditions
particulièrement intéressante et dans la
chronologie
monsieur le ministre c'est aujourd'hui
que nous vous aux 10 you know avec des
membres de votre cabinet grégory emery
votre conseiller et margot bono qui est
conseillère parlementaire
les excuses bien sûr du président
millions qu'elle président de cette
commission denquête également président
de la commission des affaires sociales
mais retenu sur son département
alors monsieur le ministre notre
commission denquête a une particularité
c'est qu'elle se tient pas posteriori
mais en même temps que les événements
qui nous réunissent et nous avons tous
eu en tête le triptyque défini par
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe protéger tester isolé la
pénurie d'équipements d'équipements de
protection a été abondamment commentée
sur les tests après une lente montée en
puissance de la france en réalise
désormais un nombre important 1,2
million chaque semaine dont certains de
par le délais deviennent tout à fait
inutile et quant à l' isolement il
semble que ce levier soit très peu
mobilisé par rapport à la quarantaine
donc un certain nombre de questions se
posent
je vais vous demander comme il est de
tradition de tenir un propos liminaire
si vous le souhaitez bien sûr dans un
délai contraint d'une dizaine de minutes
de façon à laisser place aux questions
de nos trois rapporteurs au départ puis
est question groupe et de nos
commissaires alors comme il s'agit d'une
commission denquête vous connaissez bien
la procédure
l'amande en cas de propos mensongers de
15000 euros avec une peine de prison
pouvant
et jusque 5 ans et je vais vous demander
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité de lever la main droite
et de dire je le jure je le jure ceci
étant fait monsieur le mini jeux vous
laisse la parole pour diminuer monsieur
le vice-président cher rené paul savary
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs avant de commencer j'aimerais
évidemment rendre un hommage un hommage
à celles et ceux qui ont fait face à
cette crise en première ligne dans nos
hôpitaux dans nos ehpad en médecine de
ville
sans oublier évidemment les
professionnels du domicile et toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont permis à la
france de résister aux chocs et de tenir
j'associe particulièrement dans le
contexte actuel à mon hommage
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques qui
ont pu voir ou qui peuvent revoir leurs
activités professionnelles impacté par
la gestion de crise je sais combien un
certain nombre de mesures peuvent être
difficiles à appréhender pour des
personnes qui font des efforts depuis
des semaines depuis des mois et qui ne
sont pas responsables de la situation
épidémique mais qui font l'objet de
mesures de gestion pour protéger les
populations
je veux leur redire que l'état est là
pour eux comme il l'a été depuis le
premier jour et comme il le sera jusqu'à
la fin de cette gestion de crise
je veux aussi rendre hommage et dire
vraiment ma gratitude sincère à
l'ensemble des agents des
administrations centrales des agences
régionales de santé de tous les services
de l'état
j'y associe aussi les pompiers réserve
civique et réserve sanitaire mais
également les agents des forces de
l'ordre policiers les gendarmes qui sont
mobilisés pour faire respecter des
règles dans des conditions difficiles
eux aussi depuis le depuis le premier
jour engagement a été exceptionnel ils
ont chaque jour forces et mon admiration
cette crise sanitaire le sénateur dams
et messieurs les sénateurs je la vis
depuis le premier jour de mon entrée en
fonction le 16
briet dernier j'ai été nommé ministre
alors que le virus circulait depuis peu
il y avait des personnes affectées
il y avait des foyers identifiés la
menace était réelle
en franchissant les portes de mon
ministère je n'ignorais pas cette menace
et je n'ignorais pas le risque d'une
déferlante épidémique
nous allons en parler ensemble des choix
qui ont été faits les choses difficiles
lourd et je le reconnais parfois pénible
je viens devant vous avec humilité parce
que l'humilité c'est un vaccin
c'est un vaccin efficace contre les
prophéties hasardeuses et les jugements
à l'emporte-pièce
je ne vois pas non plus ici partager une
opinion je viens décrypter avec vous les
chemins que nous avons empruntée depuis
le premier jour dans un contexte
d'incertitude jamais égalé dans notre
histoire contemporaine un contexte dans
lequel il s'est agi d'apporter des
réponses à des problèmes qui se sont
présentés chaque jour devant nous
je n'ai jamais été dans la posture de
celui qui fait des paris de celui qui
dit tout et sans filtre tous que la
crise pourrait lui inspire et surtout je
me suis efforcé d'écouter les avis
nombreux qui se sont exprimés faire le
tri entre le bon grain et l'ivraie a été
en quelque sorte mon sacerdoce
tandis qu'au même moment les français
attendaient légitimement des réponses
fermes dans une épidémie comme celle que
nous traversons le temps est un allié et
les connaissances d'aujourd'hui ne sont
pas celles d'hier il pourrait être
tentant de lire les stratégies prise
hier à l'aune des connaissances
d'aujourd'hui
je vous demande donc de tenir du compte
du caractère évolutif de ses
connaissances
de la même manière le temps politique
n'est pas le temps scientifique et cette
donnée ne doit pas échapper aux échanges
que nous aurons rechercher la lui la
vérité à la lumière des faits c'est ce à
quoi nous nous attelons aujourd'hui je
ne doute pas que cet exercice servira
autant la justesse du regard que nous
portons sur le passé récent que
l'efficacité de l'action que nous menons
aujourd'hui encore quand
l'épidémie en somme ma mission elle est
gérée la crise elle et de la gérer
aujourd'hui elle est de la gérer demain
est devant vous aujourd'hui elle est
aussi de la gérer hier nous avons tous
en tête les images de nos services de
réanimation les images des transferts
sanitaires les images d'un système de
santé mis en tension comme jamais ces
images ne sont pas de lointains
souvenirs et nous faisons aujourd'hui
tout notre possible pour qu'elle ne se
reproduise pas l'épidémie n'est pas
derrière nous et je souhaite que nous
gardions tous à l'esprit pendant cette
audition que l'événement n'est pas passé
que des français meurent toujours
aujourd'hui du courant d'un virus je le
dis je le répète tous les jours la
vigilance n'est pas une option et faire
la lumière sur les événements récents
c'est aussi ne pas s'aveugler sur la
prévenance et la persistance du risque
à ce titre je dois dire que je suis les
travaux de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale
j'ai vu un certain nombre de résumé
d'auditions hélas mes journées sont déjà
bien trop remplies pour pouvoir suivre
en intégralité les auditions et j'ai
trouvé beaucoup de qualités dans
plusieurs prises de position et
interventions qui éclaire aussi la façon
de gérer les choses et je vous en
remercie ma situation et singulière
aussi vous le savez puisque je suis
arrivé au moment où un point de non
retour avait déjà été atteint ce point
de non retour
c'est la circulation du virus ce sont
des foyers épidémiques déjà constitués
et qui allait devenir peu contrôlable et
que nous n'étions pas à l'heure en
capacité de connaître à l'époque
alors rassurez vous je ne suis pas là
pour me défausser sur qui que ce soit je
ne suis pas là pour vous dire que somme
toute nous avons fait ce que nous avons
pu avec les moyens du bord je suis là
parce que nous devons toutes et tous
apprendre d'une crise qui a placé la
santé publique au coeur de nos
préoccupations
je suis devant vous parce que le
parlement doit être fait une force
motrice dans les politiques de
protection et de prévention
je suis là parce que je suis le ministre
des solidarités et de la santé à ce
poste depuis le premier jour j'ai
toujours agi et j'ai toujours parlé avec
responsabilité et en toute transparence
ne dirais pas évidemment une autre ligne
aujourd'hui devant vous je vous remercie
et je vais répondre à vos questions
merci pour ses propos liminaires
monsieur le ministre
donc nous enchaînons avec les questions
de catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour vous vos
propos on a énormément de questions je
pense les ans comme les autres à à vous
poser parce qu'à la fois depuis le votre
arrivée en fonction après le départ
d'annie sbisa et la situation actuelle
puisqu'il hier vous avez même fait des
annonces fortes donc beaucoup beaucoup
de questions je vais essayer de deux les
laisse entrer sur trois ou quatre points
sachant que mes collègues auront
beaucoup de questions à suivre dans des
domaines variés comme les vaccins la
télémédecine bien sûr les tests et
autres
moi j'avais une première ici hier nous
avons entendu agnès buzyn qui nous a
fait dérouler très précis et très
chronologique de ce qui s'était passé
entre le janvier les premiers quarts en
chine et est le moment où elle a quitté
le ministère et l ai le sentiment que
j'ai tirée de son audition c'était que
en effet elle avait eu une une intuition
que les choses allaient évoluer qu'elle
avait à ses yeux bien préparé et qu'elle
est partie nous at elle dit en ayant
conscience d'avoir bien bordé et balisé
certains points donc comment vous
lorsque vous êtes arrivé
quelle situation vous avez trouvé et
kehl qu'est ce qui a fait qu'il a pu
apparaître des lenteurs ou une une mise
en route si je puis dire de l'appareil
d'état
avec un retard par rapport à ce qu'elle
a pu nous expliquer ça c'était ma
première question
deuxième question qui a été un point qui
revient souvent et qui revient encore ça
a était pourquoi dès le départ at-on
orienté vers le samu et en laissant des
pans entiers de la médecine de ville de
côté alors certes il y avait aussi
c'était l'idée de ne pas envoyer les
patients chez leur médecin généraliste
il y avait aussi ce qui a joué bien
évidemment le manque de protection pour
les personnels de médecine de ville pour
tous les professionnels de santé de
ville
mais elle ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû dès
le départ laisser une partie de la
médecine de ville suivre ces patients
symptomatiques plutôt d'engorger les
hôpitaux comme on l'a fait avec les
patients ça c'était ma deuxième question
est quelle est la place actuelle de la
médecine de ville
comment vous vous souhaitez leur donner
peut-être plus de moyens là où plus de
facilité dans la prise en charge
notamment des déteste ça c'était ma
deuxième le deuxième point troisième
point ce sont sur quoi vous appuyez au
fil des semaines
sur quels conseils scientifiques vous
appuyez alors pas conseil scientifique
au sens du conseil scientifique présidé
par un professeur delfraissy mais
quelles sont les données scientifiques
sur lesquelles vous appuyez on entendu
beaucoup parler de l' oms
en dix ans on a fait ça au moment où le
mms disait de le faire on se rend compte
que la gestion de l'eau mais ce qui va
d'ailleurs faire l'objet d'un audit peu
par certains points prêté à discussion
tout ça c'est tellement de troisième -
et enfin je terminerai sur les plans
hospitalier on les a tous vécu il ya eu
cette première vague de grands thèse
c'est ensuite la région parisienne et
d'autres régions qui met ça on l'a vu
après ne savait pas départ qui on attend
d'une vague qui à l'époque n'est pas
arrivé et est donc un renoncement aux
soins pour plusieurs raisons les
annulations d'intervention le fait que
les patients
les impatients ne souhaitait pas
forcément aller à manque aussi de
l'équipement ou est-ce qu'on a menées
actuellement et dans cette situation à
une mesure forte ne craignez-vous pas ou
demande comment allez-vous pallier le
fait qu'il ne faut pas qu'ils aient un
nouveau renoncement aux soins pour des
pathologies sérieuses que notamment je
pense en cancérologie ou en pathologie
cardiovasculaire je pense et puis quel
est le retour d'expérience tel n'est pas
quels retours d'expérience est ce que au
fil des semaines vous faites un vrai
retour d'expérience pour pouvoir donner
des préconisations ou aux médecins de
ville aux soignants de ville mais aussi
aux hôpitaux qui ne sont pas forcément à
la pointe des services de réanimation ou
d'hôpitaux universitaires pour qu'il
tire justement profit de ce qui a été
fait auparavant et qu'il n'est pas
nouveau un tâtonnement ou du temps perdu
a essayé de un seuil et de d'avoir une
procédure bien clair je vous remercie
sur madame la sénatrice de roche auquel
j'avais tenté de répondre
la situation à mon arrivée elle est
celle qui est effectivement d'un pays
qui se prépare à la possibilité d'une
épidémie d'un virus inconnu en
provenance de chine alors même que
l'épidémie
factuellement n'existait ni en france ni
en europe plusieurs semaines avant mon
arrivée déjà avait été identifiée la
cellule de crise corus avait été publié
les premiers bulletins d'information à
l'ensemble des structures sanitaires aux
agences régionales de santé la ministre
agnès buzyn avait déjà fait plusieurs
interventions publiques pour parler du
virus dire qu'il y avait des
possibilités que ce virus puisse rentrer
même s'il n'y avait pas de certitudes à
l'époque est en fait mon premier contact
avec l'épidémie je n'étais pas ministre
j'étais député de grenoble et je trouve
qu'au chu de grenoble était hospitalisé
un monsieur anglais ainsi que ses
enfants qui avaient été dans le classeur
de contamines montjoie la ministre agnès
buzyn s'étant rendus à leur rencontre
c'était sur ma circonscription je suis
médecin également dans cet hôpital
je vais naturellement accompagnée je
suis allé à la rencontre des équipes de
médecins apex du service de maladies
infectieuses qui avait mis en place un
isolement hospitalier des personnes
malades et qu'à contacter en
l'occurrence ces personnes avaient des
symptômes qui s'apparentent est pour le
coup un rhume et pas une de formes
graves à contamines montjoie salue par
ailleurs constater que l'ensemble des
dispositions et la grande réactivité à
contamines montjoie avec la capacité d'
isoler les cas contactez fermer les
structures qui nécessitait d'être fermée
de tester les populations qui
nécessitait d'être testé et un grand
nombre de tests avaient été réalisés
tous négatifs en dehors de quelques
personnes positif cinq ou six au total
qui avait fréquenté le même chalet que
la personne qui revenait de singapour et
qui avait transmis le virus sur
contamines montjoie donc un cluster qui
aurait pu démarrer très fort contamines
montjoie aurait pu être le début d'une
épidémie précoce avant l'italie
il n'a pas été parce que la gestion a
été optimales du début à la fin je le
dis d'autant plus que j'étais que
parlementaire et certainement pas aux
commandes s'il n'y avait pas eu la
vigilance des médecins dans cette
station de ski
et bah eu déjà des communications
internationales pour pouvoir dire
attention il y a eu des cas qui sont qui
peuvent éventuellement avoir transmis le
virus sur le territoire national ce
n'est pas eu la préparation de l' agence
régionale de santé de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et s'il n'y avait pas eu
déjà la préparation des équipes
hospitalières pour pouvoir accueillir
dans les conditions optimales des
patients en isolement contamines
montjoie aurait pu tout à fait le départ
d'une épidémie bien plus précoce pour
moi c'est la marque d'un pays qui avait
su se préparer
il y avait déjà le déclenchement du
stade 1 du plan orsec ce que la ministre
agnès buzyn vous a dit hier le 14
février avant mon arrivée le jour le
premier décès avaient été enregistrés le
stade 2 sera déclenchée par mes soins
deux semaines plus tard consistant à
renforcer les mesures de confinement
pour les foyers de propagation notamment
dans l'oise où nous avions dû fermer des
écoles et interdire des rassemblements
et au niveau national nous avons
interdit les manifestations supérieure à
5000 personnes en milieu fermé donc la
préparation du système de santé je le
dis et je rends hommage à l'action qui a
été conduite par ma prédécesseure elle
était réelle et je peux vous dire madame
la ministre que lorsqu'elle vous dit en
commission d'enquêté hier qu'elle était
sans doute la mieux préparée des pays
environnants mettant rendu moi même
quelques jours après ma nomination à
rome pour rencontrer les ministres de la
santé et deux semaines après ma
nomination à bruxelles pour discuter
avec l'ensemble de mes homologues
européens dont une majorité importante
se demandaient pourquoi est-ce qu'on
réunisse et en urgence les ministres du
concept de du conseil de l'europe compte
tenu qu'ils avaient pas d'épidémie en
europe
je peux vous dire qu'effectivement
niveau d' alerte était important en
france comparé à beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de boissons qui nous entoure ça
c'est pour la partie qui ne concerne pas
mais c'est je tiens un lien sur
l'orientation l'orientation par le samu
vers le samu plutôt vers la médecine de
ville bien coûter la doctrine initial
était dès qu'on identifie dès qu'on
suspecte un malade potentiel du
coronavirus on doit l'isoler on doit
l'isoler il n'y a pas encore
d'épidémique galopant dans le pays en
tout cas on ne le sait pas et donc il
était important fondamental de casser
toute chaîne de contamination avant même
qu'elles se développent et donc le
passage par le samu était le moyen dès
lors qu'il avait une ciste
s'ils ont une confirmation de cas
d'isoler les personnes en milieu
hospitalier c'est ce qui a été fait à
contamines montjoie
c'est ce qui a été fait avec le
rapatriement des expatriés de one
c'est ce qui a été fait systématiquement
dans tout ce qu'on appelait la première
phase empêcher des russes d'entrer et
l'empêché de se transmettre la dresser
ses patients la médecine de ville ça
comportait plusieurs risques que vous
avez vous même soulevé dans une salle
d'attenté si quelqu'un sans protection
qui une suspicion de qu'ovide vient pour
consulter son médecin il peut contaminer
d'autres personnes il peut contaminer
son médecin par ailleurs les outils de
mesure n'était pas aussi optimum en
médecine de ville et c'est tout à fait
normal que si c'était à l'hôpital il n'a
jamais été question d'écarter les
médecins du dispositif d'ailleurs il
était prévu est convenu que si
l'épidémie commencé à diffuser à
l'instar de ce qu'ont fait dans les
épidémies grippales
il se serait on passerait un diagnostic
clinique des cas symptomatiques réalisée
par des médecins en médecine de ville
vous me posez la question de la suite
ensuite nous avons décidé d'hospitaliser
les patients que si c'était nécessaire
lorsque le virus à diffuser qu'on était
passé à un stade ultérieur de diffusion
du virus qu'on n'était plus en train
d'empêcher le virus d'entrer et qu'on
voulait limiter sa propre sa propagation
était hospitalisé les cas sévères les
autres cas étaient adressées en
isolement chez eux ou en structures
hôtelières lorsqu'il n'était pas en
capacité de s'isoler correctement chez
eux dès lors nous sommes rentrés dans ce
qu'on applique depuis des dizaines
d'années dans notre pays c'est à dire le
diagnostic clinique syndromique avec des
réseaux de médecins sentinelles qui font
remonter les données et tout cas
symptomatiques et vocaux vide a été
considéré comme co vite jusqu'à preuve
du contraire
dès lors tout cas symptomatiques qu'on
considérait comme un risque de qu'ovide
se voyait isolés le temps nécessaire
vous pouvez aujourd'hui la question de
la médecine de ville
un missile de villèle un rôle central la
médecine a un rôle un rôle central
elle va avoir un rôle donc encore plus
important alors que les rhumes les
rhinopharyngites les angines la grippe
vont arriver dans notre pays ils vont
nécessiter de faire la part des choses
entre ce qui relèverait du coc vidé ce
qui relèverait de tout autre virus
hélas friands de la période automnale et
hivernale
donc la médecine de ville a toute sa
place
je travaille d'ailleurs avec les
syndicats est l'ordre professionnel pour
anticiper avec eux quel rôle pourrait
être le leur notamment en matière de
diagnostic pour cela il me manque des
éléments factuels avant tout pouvoir
vous répondre notamment j'ai saisi la
haute autorité de santé sur la place des
médecins généralistes dans le diagnostic
clinique des personnes symptomatique
j'aurai la réponse
j'aurai la réponse prochainement mais
sans attendre j'ai fait aussi le choix à
la sénatrice de développer la
télémédecine et de manière inédite dans
notre pays je crois que nous réalisions
quelques dizaines de milliers d' actes
de télémédecine par an dans notre pays à
un million d' actes de télémédecine par
semaine à cela plusieurs raisons j'ai
décidé nous avons décidé de faire
prendre en charge à 100% les
consultations télémédecine de simplifier
par tous les moyens y compris par des
moyens qui jusqu'ici n'étaient pas
autorisées comme skype comme moi tu
zappes même autorisé les consultations
téléphoniques même autorisé la
téléconsultation pour les infirmières
pour les kinés et ça a permis aux
médecins sans s'exposer sans exposer les
autres malades de participer grandement
à la prise en charge des malades à la
phase épidémique 7 télémédecine poursuit
j'ai fait le choix de continuer avec les
mesurettes exception pour ne pas faire
s'effondrer la télémédecine pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée en avril 11 % des
consultations se sont faites en
télémédecine allant même jusqu'à 55 %
pour l'activité des entreprises des
endocrinologues ou 48 % pour l'activité
des pneumologues donc on a massivement
développée ça vous posez ensuite la
question des données scientifiques je
vais pas vous faire ici le tour sauf si
vous le souhaitez de l'ensemble des
acteurs scientifiques qui éclairent les
décisions et de l'organisation de l'état
sachez que les données scientifiques et
sont d'autant plus simple à suivre
lorsqu'elle son corps au corroborés par
plusieurs organismes nationaux et
internationaux
en l'occurrence j'ai eu un certain
consensus entre l' oms
le cdc au niveau européen le conseil des
ministres européens de la santé le
conseil scientifique a été mis en place
la direction générale de la santé qui le
bras armé de la politique de santé
publique et de sécurité sanitaire du
ministère les autorités de synthes
centralisés et décentralisés le haut
conseil de santé publique
la haute autorité de santé les agences
régionales de santé les organismes de
recherche comme l'inserm l'institut
pasteur
tous les acteurs sont venus éclairer les
décisions éclairées les doctrines
l'échangé par endroits l'académie de
médecine a joué aussi un rôle en cela et
on a pu avoir des doctrines qui ont
évolué au fur et à mesure que les
connaissances évoluent et je trouve ça
assez simple que nous puissions adapter
les doctrines et les stratégies à au fur
et à mesure que les connaissances
scientifiques safin et puis nous
disposons en outil de pilotage d'une
batterie d'indicateurs très importante
j'en ai présenté un certain ambrières
l'incidence des incidents des personnes
âgées le taux de positivité déteste la
saturation des réa le r d'admissions aux
urgences le herd appels à sos médecins
etc etc
sur le plan hospitalier moi je n'ai
aucun regret madame la sénatrice mme
alors aucun regret d'avoir anticipé le
plan blanc généralisé à l'échelle du
pays
je me souviens que les premiers jours
effectivement j'avais des remontées
d'établissements de santé publics ou
privés me disant mais vous nous empêchez
d'opérer les malades alors qu'on n'a pas
de covin la particularité d'une épidémie
avec un virus aussi contagieux et aussi
invasif que le coronavirus sais que ça
va très vite
ça va très vite et quand ça monte ça
monte très vite si nous prenons par
exemple des mesures importantes à
marseille et en région paca
c'est parce que ça va très vite à
marseille en paca nous sommes à plus de
30 % de taux de saturation des reals par
des patients qu'aux vide j'ai présenté
hier l'évolution des chiffres sur des
régions comme la région aura ou la
région ile de france et on peut se
souvenir qu'à l'automne au printemps
dernier pardon et à l'automne dernier et
à l'hiver dernier au printemps dernier
c2c monte très vite plusieurs centaines
de réanimation chaque jour plusieurs
centaines de réanimation chaque jour
lorsque vous êtes dans une situation où
les réanimations sont occupées par de la
chirurgie programmée et que vous avez
peu de place devant vous vous mettez en
danger des centaines des milliers de
vies nous avons sauvé des centaines et
des milliers de vies en activant un plan
blanc anticipé en vidant les
réanimations en amont parce que nous
n'aurions pas pu le faire si la vague
vu la vitesse qu'elle avait au printemps
dernier nous avait pris de court
donc l'établissement ont tous participé
et nous avons augmenté de façon quand je
dis on sent des territoires des
soignants des agences qui ont augmenté
les lidd réa pour faire face à la vague
et encore une fois les hôpitaux et les
réanimations ont tenu aujourd'hui la
situation est différente la matière
grise puisque nous avons des indicateurs
plus fins meilleure connaissance du
virus nous avons des modélisations sur
lesquels desquels nous inspirons que
j'ai présentée hier l'institut pasteur
notamment qui permettent d'appréhender
semaine après semaine l'évolution du
nombre de réa et donc nous avons mis en
place des indicateurs par territoire
voire par hôpital pour donner à chacun
ses propres outils de gestion et lorsque
cela devient nécessaire un hôpital se
voit contrainte d'annuler des opérations
de vider des blocs opératoires de les
transformer en salle de réanimation du
personnel a été formé d expérience de la
gestion de crise ont été partagés pour
pouvoir faire face à cette crise
épidémique et l'autre choix que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas
annuler toutes les chirurgies programmé
parce que beaucoup de malades ont
retardé leurs opérations
une dame qui doit faire poser une
prothèse de hanche parce qu'elles
souffrent le martyre et qui se voit
différée de six mois son opération ne
peut pas supporter qu'on l'a on l'a
différents corps de trois mois un
patient qui doit être greffés doit
pouvoir être greffés au moment venu
donc nous faisons nous jouons
aujourd'hui pas nous jouons mais en tout
cas nous travaillons à partir des
différents indicateurs pour annuler le
moins de choses possibles
que vous dire d'autre par rapport à
votre question c'est tout je crois que
j'ai répondu à l'ensemble de vos
questions sinon vous me direz jeu
complet sur le retour d'expérience
la question je vous la pose c'est parce
que comment les médecins généralistes
actuellement sont informés de la
conduite à tenir alors ils le font parce
qu'entre eux ils fonctionnent ils ont
une habitude mais s il ya des
préconisations des recommandations qui
ont été données et si oui par qui on
parle de sociétés savantes des sites des
collèges est haute mais s il ya des
données pratiques
un médecin généraliste ou seul dans son
cabinet est-ce qu'il a une vraie
procédure qui lui a été mise en place
et puis ma question elle portait sur ce
retour d'expérience notamment puisqu'on
voit maintenant que le virus est un peu
partout dans des hôpitaux qui sont pas
forcément à la poigne comme on a pu être
au début avec les les hôpitaux du grand
s les hôpitaux parisiens où les cheveux
pareil quel est le degré d'information
des médecins qui reçoivent des patients
qu'aux vide dans les hôpitaux généraux
dans certains départements sur un canton
nous a dit un cluster dans l'aveyron
comment les centres hospitaliers de
l'aveyron ont eu parce que ce qui est
important c'est qu'il ait pas de perte
de temps à essayer de mettre en place
une prise en charge alors que c'est déjà
été fait avec l'île de france par
exemple j'ai tiré parti très vite de
l'expérience des du grand s et puis pour
compléter avant de vous c'est de
l'apport vous n'avez pas répondu sur la
qualité des données de l' oms avait posé
sachez qu'il y a un outil de
communication qui fonctionne très bien
qui s'appelle le dgs urgents qui est un
bulletin d'informations extrêmement
complet parfois on a pu vous dire qu'il
était trop et parfois nous avons fait
plus synthétique pour nous assurer que
chacun appréhende et le bon niveau
d'information il ya 800 mille abonnés
qui sont des professionnels de santé
parmi lesquels évidemment les médecins
hospitaliers et libéraux
ces bulletins ont été envoyées de
manière extrêmement régulière par
ailleurs il est de nombreux échanges et
il ya toujours de nombreux échanges avec
les syndicats des sociétés savantes les
ordres professionnels tous les
protocoles de prise en charge des
patients que vides ont été travaillés
avec les sociétés savantes le collège de
la médecine générale et des fiches
pratiques donc ont été diffusés après
chaque concertation les ans
professionnelles les syndicats ont eu
des échanges hebdomadaire systématique
et organisée avec les services du
ministère ont été régulièrement en
contact avec mon cabinet y compris
d'ailleurs avec moi ils ont mon
téléphone et on s'appelle j'ai encore
appelé le président du syndicat mg
france je crois que c'était gelé embêter
je sais plus c'était samedi ou dimanche
matin pour discuter avec lui des
perspectives d'évolution de la place des
généralistes dans le diagnostic et
faisant aussi le constat je vous donne
un exemple mais c'est très concret je
les appelais jacques bâtisse tenir
exemple j'ai fait le constat que il n'ya
plus que 15% aujourd'hui du contact
racing qui est fait par les médecins
généralistes
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on repasse un
message aux patients constitution
diagnostiqués positifs pour qu'ils aient
le réflexe d'appeler leur médecin
il m'a dit oui je devais annoncé hier en
rappelant à l'ensemble des français que
lorsqu'ils ont un test positif il faut
pas qu'ils hésitent à appeler leur
médecin par télémédecine par téléphone
pas forcément en allant le voir pour
qu'il puisse les éclairer les orienter
préparer leur mise à l'abri et leur
donner tous conseils utiles voire
assurer la surveillance
les médecins ont toute leur place dans
le dispositif donc c'est un exemple
monsieur ni l'autre nous avons reçu ce
matin même un médecin généraliste il
nous le disait qu'effectivement il avait
contacté a mais le médecin généraliste
ne peut pas rentrer directement les cas
contacts qu'il connaît par rapport à la
plate forme puisque c'est la cpam qui
elle fait les plans comptables ou est ce
sont des choses pratiques comme ça qu'on
essaye de tirer d'expérience parce que
les médecins le savent bien il y en a
ici dans cette assemblée qui sont aux
sénateurs qu'ils continuent à exercer
leur profession quand véritablement le
contact direct avec la population
c'est quelque chose de sain voyez c'est
un petit peu là dedans que l'on essaye
de d'avancé le médecin de vous avoir les
médecins généralistes ont totalement axé
amélie pro peuvent pas en connaissent
les patients ils peuvent pas entrer
directement en disant voilà telle ou
telle personne on gagnerait du temps par
rapport à la cpmc la cpm qui leur dit un
certain nombre de données
après avoir pris contact avec le malade
alors que ces données ils les ont pas ce
que eux sont en contact avec le malade
voyez il ya deux processus ça qu'est ce
qui nous a été dit c'est que quand la bo
quand le lavaur le test est positif le
laboratoire rentrer dans l'application
cpm le taux positifs que nous
plus après il rentrait de façon
postérieurs pour par exemple ils mettent
les membres de la famille et autres donc
ça ils ne peuvent pas le faire
d'accord c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose pardon les médecins les médecins
libéraux et médecins hospitaliers sont
chargés du ce qu'on appelle le tracking
de niveau 1
c'est le premier volet c'est le premier
volet d'ailleurs 65% du contact racing
au début de l'été et des fêtes un
médecin comme quoi c'est faisable
les deux tiers des patients tracé elle
était par les médecins ça a chuté
pendant l'été les médecins ont accès à
amélie pros ils ont accès à contacter le
ville qui leur permet de rentrer donné
la question de modifier des données dans
un dispositif qui a entériné le traçage
des cas contact est une question plus
complexe qui passe par amélie pro
puisque c'est un leurre alors
l'assurance maladie qui prend le relais
vous avez ces trois niveaux le niveau 1
c'est des médecins de terrain niveau 2
c'est l'assurance maladie et pour les
clusters et les cas complexes
c'est l' agence régionale de santé qui
s'en occupe maintenant je suis tout à
fait disposé à appeler le médecin en
pratique dans mon quotidien dans
l'exercice de ministre je surprends
parfois les gens en les appelant avec
mon téléphone assez spontanément quand
j'entends qu'il ya des difficultés qui
sont jours pour qu'il m'explique et
qu'on partage et parfois ils ont raison
parfois c'est nous mais peu importe
qu'il a raison la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on avance donc je regarderai
et je demande à mon cabinet de vérifier
ce point en particulier je vous ai
répondu du coup oui sur la question des
données l'om est à écouter les données
le ms moi je ne suis pas chargé de
l'évaluation de ms il ya une mission
d'évaluation qui a été initiée de l' oms
je me suis rendu au siège de la msa la
rencontre du docteur tedros ainsi que
mon collègue et homologue le ministre
allemand de la santé jens panne pour
rappeler notre soutien à la structure
parce qu'on a besoin de l'om s on a
besoin d'une autorité d'une organisation
mondiale comme le remake mais il faut
évidemment faire un retour d'expérience
sur la façon dont les données ont été
gérés traiter les recommandations à
porter et c'est toute la lumière qui
sera faite sur cette question c'est pas
du tout moment de jeter le discrédit sur
une institution surtout surtout sans
fondement mais par contre c'est vrai
qu'elle a joué un rôle important dans la
crise puisqu'elle a apporté une
expertise elle avait un regard
international plus aiguë que le nôtre le
regard sur la situation chinoise et
première semaine il est plus aisé de la
voir
travers une institution mondiale qui
partage des données en transparence
qu'en passant des coups de téléphone des
amis chinois donc le ms nous a été utile
elle a fait elle-même évoluer ses
recommandations mais quand j'en discute
quand j'en ai discuté avec le docteur
toon sont évidents mais là sur les tests
sur les masques vous avez évolué de
crime
les médecins tous les deux on sait très
bien que les connaissances changent
évoluent que la recherche a progressé et
donc il est normal qu'on fasse évoluer
les choses progressivement il aurait été
tout à fait possible si on prend la
question des masques par exemple vous
allez m'emmener sur cette question j'ai
pas envie de déflorer le sujet mais il
aurait été tout à fait aussi possible
qu'on ce que les décide que l'intuition
en tout cas d'après les données d'un
scientifique dans les ems disposait
qu'elle conclut qu'il n'y avait pas de
passage aérosols du gorna virus et que
donc le port du masque mais ça ne
s'imposait pas envoyé donc elle a été
capable d'évoluer elle l'a dit et chaque
fois qu'elle a évolué nous sommes
inspirés entre autres de ces
recommandations nous les avons pas
toujours suivis parfois nous avons
anticipé un certain nombre de décisions
comme sur la question du port du masque
merci sylvie vermeillet merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre vous
avez dit que nous étions là pour
discuter des choix qui ont été faits je
pense que nous sommes aussi là pour
discuter des choix que vous pourriez
faire
vu l'expérience dont vous disposez
aujourd'hui j'aurai quatre questions
précises la première c'est quel est le
regard que vous portez sur l'île
l'efficience ou l'inefficience de santé
publique france leur leur absence sur la
gestion des strophes des stocks
stratégiques
du coup c'est ma caisse ma deuxième
question la question des stocks
stratégiques quelle assurance qu'elle
garantit pouvez vous nous donner
aujourd'hui sur le niveau des stocks
stratégiques en médicaments en
équipements de protection individuelle
et puis quelle est votre position dès
aujourd'hui quant aux vaccins qui sont
annoncées même si ce sont des vaccins
partiels annoncés pour la fin de l'année
ou premier trimestre 2021 comment est ce
que vous vous assurer que nous pourrons
que les français pourront disposer
autant que de besoin
troisième question avec la reprise
d'épidémie est ce que vous veillez
aujourd'hui à l'intégration du privé
parmi le public avec le public est ce
que vous veillez à cette synergie
on a pu voir au cours de nos auditions
que alors que des hôpitaux publics qui
était saturé il existait des cliniques
vide et est ce que vous vous avez pris
les moyens de remédier à cela et
quatrième question avec l'expérience qui
est la vôtre dans cette gestion de crise
est ce que vous imaginez reconsidérer le
rôle et les moyens des hôpitaux de
proximité
merci
compte cinq questions à la sénatrice
d'abord le regard que je peux porter sur
l'efficience de santé publique france
certains publient france a été au
rendez-vous de l'épidémiologie il a été
au rendez vous de la distribution santé
publique france a été percuté par sa
première grande crise sanitaire
d'envergure affectant le territoire
français et la population française dans
son ensemble
je vais pas vous faire ici le rappel de
l'intégration de l'eprus dans un
dispositif rénové qui était santé
publique trans je crois que l'ensemble
ou presque l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale dans cette
enceinte en fonction lorsque la loi a
été présenté à voter cette intégration
qui faisait plutôt sens mais je ne me
prive pas de réinterroger pour l'avenir
santé public français est est une agence
structuré avec beaucoup de scientifiques
qui produisent beaucoup de données qui
sont précieuses au quotidien et qui
s'est retrouvé en plus de cela d'une
mission logistique qu'elle assure avec
le stock avec les gestions mais avec une
mission de distribution dans l'urgence
il a fallu à partir d'un seul entrepôt
nationale à marolles organiser la
distribution dans chaque hôpital dans
chaque officine de masques de production
dans l'urgence c'est aussi ça peut
réinterroger la façon demain de stocker
les matériaux de protection est ce qu'un
seul stocks centralisée doit être la
solution
mon avis mon sentiment personnage il
donnait pas mes sentiments ici mais pour
avoir passé énormément de temps de coups
de fil nuitées jours pour essayer de
comprendre comment faire sortir les
camions d'un entrepôt pour à les arroser
l'ensemble du territoire où les gens
attendaient légitimement des masques je
pense qu'on fera différemment mais
d'ailleurs votre commission d' enquête a
aussi pour but de nous éclairer et
éclairer les décisions et d'annoncés
très tôt au parlement je souhaitais
m'appuyer sur les travaux des
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat pour dessiner le système de
demain
les stocks stratégiques madame la
sénatrice je ne devrais pas vous dire de
bêtises dans les chiffres mais sur les
médicaments
on a annoncé qu'on avait reconstituer
des stocks notamment de médicaments à
usage de d'anesthésie-réanimation de
manière à être capable de traiter
jusqu'à 29 mille malades alors pas 29
mille malades en même temps nous
n'aurions pas les lits pour cela mais
jusqu'à 29 mille malades là où nous
avons accueilli au total dans la
première vague 17 mille malades
c'est important et ses stocks de
médicaments stratégique en réanimation
anesthésie
on l'avait dit avec edouard philippe
premier ministre de l'époque c'était un
point de tension crucial on ne sait
jamais tomber à zéro mais alors il a
fallu déployer des trésors d'ingéniosité
de là sur le territoire pour pouvoir
basculer des petits stocks dormants de
certains hôpitaux cliniques et vers
d'autres hôpitaux qui risquait d'en
manquer le fait est qu aucun malade n'a
été extubée faute de pouvoir le
maintenir en coma artificiel par les
médicaments haddock mais c'est pas
forcément passé loin donc nous avons
pris la décision de reconstituer des
stocks plus importants beaucoup plus
importants que ceux dont nous disposions
surtout dans un contexte où la demande
mondiale explose est avec des
consommations parfois multiplié par
mille par mille peu de même savoir qui
est des pays producteurs les principaux
pays producteurs qui se sont retrouvés à
manquer de ce type de médicaments
lorsqu'ils ont été eux mêmes confrontés
à la vague épidémique et pour se fournir
en médicaments dans la gestion en pleine
crise sanitaire j'ai passé un grand
nombre d'appels de tir de la diplomatie
internationale pour obtenir des envois
et des arrivées supplémentaires
donc c'était tendu et donc nous devons
faire plus attention à l'avenir et c'est
pour ça que nous avons un stock plus
important sur les masques nous l'avons
dit nous voulons un milliard de masques
de stocks stratégiques d'état 800
millions de masques chirurgicaux 200
millions de masques ffp2 nous sommes
quasiment arrivé à reconstituer ce stock
à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle ce
sera le cas dans la semaine où les
quinze jours qui arrivent
où il nous manque peut-être 100 millions
de masques chirurgicaux à date et nous
avons quelques 60 millions de masques
ffp2 de plus que ce que prévoient nos
objectifs de stocks stratégiques
nous avons également des millions de
masques chirurgicaux pédiatrique et nous
avons de quoi équiper les lits de
réanimation pour monter nos leaders et à
jusqu'à quatorze mille au prix d'efforts
énorme mais nous serions en état de le
faire nous avons les respirateurs les
médicaments et du matériel de
sur le bac tard je ne sais pas s'il doit
vous donner ma position en tout cas la
position du ministre de la santé c'est
qu'un vaccin
il sera proposé aux français quand il
existera et quand il aura démontré par
les études cliniques correctement
réalisée en population générale qui est
à la fois efficace et sûre comment est
ce que nous faisons pour anticiper cela
nous avons créé un consortium de quatre
pays avec les pays bas l'italie
l'allemagne et la france nous avons
prospecté auprès d'un laboratoire qui
était le premier laboratoire a je crois
en tout cas l'un des tout premiers à
envisager une phase iii c'est à dire les
phases d'expérimentation du vaccin en
population générale
un laboratoire anglais du nom
d'astrazeneca avec un projet de
recherche développé par l'université
d'oxford recherche publique nous avons
travaillé avec ce laboratoire et nous
avons fait un contrat d'intention de
commande de 300 de 300 millions de doses
de ces vaccins alors jusqu'à négocier
d'ailleurs le prix il est pas cher en
l'occurrence pour le jour où si ce
vaccin s'avérait sûr et efficace nous
puissions en disposer pour tout le
territoire européen et la france peut se
targuer à la demande du président de la
république d'avoir à chaque fois a
systématiquement organisé les choses
pour que nous disposions de doses
supplémentaires afin d'aider des pays
qui sont en difficulté pour pouvoir s'en
procurer par la suite la commission
européenne nous l'avons proposé la
commission européenne de reprendre le
flambeau de lui avons confié ce pré
contrat et la commission européenne à
organiser des comités d'experts avec des
experts issus de nombreux pays dont la
france daguerre qui se charge de
prospecter auprès de chacun des
laboratoires sérieux qui a une phase
avancée de développement de vaccins de
manière à ce que le premier qui trouve
un bon vaccin sûr et efficace on soit
sûr d'en avoir sans délai pour
l'ensemble de la population européenne
sur les recommandations d'usagé de ce
vaccin anti qu'ovide et qu'il sera
proposé dans quelles conditions je ne
peux pas vous répondre ça va dépendre
des données d'études cliniques des
vaccins
il y aura évidemment une saisine de la
haute autorité de santé en urgence
lorsque nous aurons ces données sur le
privé parmi le public
j'ai évidemment lu la presse twitter
j'ai appelé beaucoup de directeurs
d'établissements lorsqu'on me disais que
tel établissement n'étaient pas
mobilisées dans le privé alors qu'ils
ont cherché des vies dressage
garantir que quand vous êtes ministre de
la santé que vous passez vos jours et
vos nuits à chercher le moindre l'hydre
et à organiser des transferts sanitaire
que vous appelez des ministres à
l'étranger pour leur demander s'ils ont
des places pour vos malades que vous
montez des tgv en moins de 48 heures ce
qui n'avait jamais été fait dans notre
pays pour pouvoir transporter des
malades là où il y avait de la place
il faudrait pardon de l'expression
complètement abrutis pour considérer
qu'ils auraient des places dans lé real
de l'opic de la clique du coin et ne
serait pas grave on est d'accord
bon je crois pas être complètement
abrutis et je crois pas que les ars sont
complètement abrutis et je ne pense pas
que les médecins des établissements
soient complètement abruti s'il ya eu
des retards parfois à la mobilisation du
secteur privé systématiquement les
agences de santé dans les territoires
ont été mobilisés pour leur dire qu'il
avait cessé il ya eu peut-être eu des
situations dans une région dont vous
avez auditionné le directeur général
monsieur le vice président de la
commission qui a pu mobile entraîné une
nécessité de ma part quelques appels de
sensibilisation mais très vite la
situation est rentrée dans l'ordre et
j'ajoute que un moment où les cliniques
certes on me faisait encore remarqué que
des cliniques n'était pas mobiliser
suffisamment le président la fédération
hospitalière privée monsieur la mine
gherbi peut-être que vous l'avez
auditionné publié des communiqués pour
dire que c'était factuellement faux et
que les cliniques étaient mobilisés donc
je vous le redis touly utile pour des
malades en réanimation par réanimation
en hôpital de proximité ou en chu en
clinique privée ou à l'hôpital public
touly utile doit être utilisé doit etre
doit être et je vous le dis nous n'avons
pas manqué d'utiliser l'ensemble des
parcs hospitalier est pas un regard dans
chaque unité de chaque hôpital vous le
pensez bien
mais les directeurs généraux des ars les
délégués départementaux long et je peux
vous dire que ils n'ont pas ménagé leurs
efforts pour évacuer les patients qu'ils
de nécessiter d'autres pays parfois et
qu'avant de faire cela ils ont
évidemment ce sont évidemment assuré que
tous les lits dryats sur le territoire
était ce une mini utilisé d'une région
je connais bien je puis vous dire qu'il
ya eu des difficultés au départ dans
certaines régions ça a été largement
remonté et comment tu es d'accord voilà
parce que c'est la réalité
on a été confronté directement avec ça
ça ne s'est pas passé partout mais
soyons lucides il faut reconnaître qu'il
ya des endroits où il ya eu des
difficultés pas c'est pas pour autant
une critique c'est
tous qu'il ne faut pas et c'était la
question de notre rapporteur recommencer
donc précisément
y at-il eu des mesures pour faire en
sorte que ça se fluidifie encore mieux
ses relations entre le privé et public
oui moi aussi j'avais j'avais appelé
laminé gharbi au moment où il y avait
ces articles qui qui qui apparaissait on
l'a auditionné dans le cadre d'auditions
à porter que j'ai fait il ya eu il ya eu
pendant quelques jours des points où il
ya eu en effet une latence entre le
moment où on a mobilisé le le privé moi
ce qui m'intéresserait et ce qui
l'intéresserait pour notre commission
denquête c'est qu'on est un peu
justement ce travelling arrière en
disant tel ou tel hôpital telle clinique
pendant deux trois jours n'a eu qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse voir la réalité
parce que on est sur un témoignage d'un
tel année lui qui nous dit et c'est dans
mon département tels la clinique n'a pas
été mobilisés mais il faut qu'on se base
sur des choses vraiment factuel donc si
on peut avoir un moment un panorama réel
bien sûr mais ce qui s'est passé là la
fédération la fhp peut nous le faire
mais si on peut croiser les données
laissent acheter les votes ce serait
bien vous m'étonnez je vais vous dire
deux choses
à un moment donné je me suis dit est ce
que c'est une réalité j'ai appelé dg drs
je leur ai mis le dg de la grèce de la
région concernée j'ai mis un petit peu
de pression
deuxièmement j'ai dit très clairement
qu'avec les données pmi 6 et des données
informatiques d'hospitalisation issue
d'hospitalisation des patients tout
patient tout patient qui auraient été
opérés en chirurgie programmée puis
adresser dans un service de soins
intensifs ou de réanimation d'une
clinique du territoire alors même que
les plans blancs étaient activées non
seulement ne donnerait pas lieu au
paiement des soins à l'établissement par
l'assurance maladie et que je
m'occuperai personnellement d'établir un
dispositif de sanctions donc j'ai été
extrêmement clair sur le sujet par
contre quand vous parlez de remonter et
de commentaires monsieur le sénateur
mois une fois j'ai été interpelé un
sujet d'une clinique qui avait me disait
ton syli de l'animation en appelant
cette clinique le directeur m'a dit oui
j'ai aussi de réanimation mais je ne
peux pas prendre de malades qu vite
pourquoi parce qu'il faisait c'était
délit qui faisait partie de ce qu'on
appelle les lits non qu'ovide puisqu'on
a évidemment garder délit non que vite
dans les hôpitaux
si quelqu'un a fait un avc très grave
fait un infarctus ou si quelqu'un se
fait opérer d'un cancer
il faut opérer dans l'urgence on va pas
lui dire désolé les lits sont réservés
pour les patients coli dont il y avait
des lits également dans le secteur
public qui était réservé pour des
patients non qu'ovide et autres et
d'autre part il m'a dit il ya une
clinique aussi dans sur le territoire
qui n'a pas forcément s'est dit plein
mais attention on lui a demandé de céder
ses médicaments de réanimation et
l'équipe d'eire est venu renforcer
l'équipe hospitalière pour faire face à
l'augmentation des lits donc attention
enfin je veux dire chez moi je voudrais
pas qu'on qu'on laisse à penser deux
choses 1 qu'il y aurait des
professionnels de santé avec la vocation
chevillée au corps qui auraient attendu
le chaland en voyant que tout
s'effondrait en tout cas tout menacé de
s'effondrer autour de je ne crois pas
une seconde je ne crois pas une seconde
et deuxièmement je voudrais pas qu'on
laisse à penser que des directeurs de
structures de territoriales ce soit
entre guillemets désintéresser du sujet
de la mobilisation du parc hospitalier
parce que j'ai vécu la crise avec eux je
peux dire qu'ils ont vécu la crise avec
moi que nous étions parfaitement nous
visitons j'entends ce que vous dites
comme remarque nous aurons les données
pmi ci qui nous permettront d'ailleurs
déclaré et si je vous le dis c'est un
excellent l'établissement n'a pas était
loyal dans sa chute dans cette gestion
qui ce dont je dis je doute je rendrai
volontiers public puisque jean jaurès
agents des comme ça monsieur le ministre
il ne s'agit pas de ça il s'agit
d'établissements qui avait des livres
parce que il était prêt à tendre des
malades qu vide et ils ne nous ont
jamais vu venir
voilà ce n'est pas vraiment aimé tout à
fait mais on voulait donnera ya aucun
souci là dessus mais ce n'est pas une
remise en cause ça veut dire que c'est
un problème de fonctionnement
d'articulation entre le public et le
privé ne faisons pas une situation qu'a
été idylliques
il ya eu quelques problèmes et c'est
logique ces problèmes là et le but de
notre commission s'est pas de les
dénoncer c'est de faire en sorte que ça
ne se reproduise plus c'est la raison
pour laquelle la question de notre
reporter et précise
vous avez pris des mesures pour que ce n
est bien sûr de la fluidité les liens
entre le public et le privé
j'ajoute de choses si vous permettez
après je serai volonté la parole dans
les premières semaines il fallait de
l'ecc mots pour faire de la réanimation
avec les réanimateurs disait qu'il
fallait aussi un équipement en ecmo en
cd en circulation extra corps
aurel or beaucoup d'établissements
certains établissements privés non
n'était pas équipée ensuite on a pu
basculer et donc utiliser donc attention
et des gens qui n'ont pas vu leurs lits
exploités pour des raisons médicales
d'équipement et d'organisation et
lorsque les recommandations et évoluer
ce que je veux vous dire monsieur le
sénateur c'est quoi je suis prêt à tout
entendre
parce que tout dysfonctionnement doit
être corrigé surtout vu la période que
nous sommes en train de vivre ce que je
demande c'est que lorsqu'on m'interpelle
sur des sujets comme celui ci on soit
également précis en allant jusqu'à me
donner les établissements les dates les
équipes à partir de là je peux faire un
travail de ré texte qui soit
satisfaisant or pardonnez moi monsieur
le sénateur et c'est pas du tout ne le
prenez pas mal à la rapporteure pour
vous mais quand on me dit il y a eu des
établissements qu'ils écoutent et c'est
formidable mais moi on me dit qu'il n'ya
pas eu d'établissement qui donc corrigé
le son essieu notre corps que j'ai hélas
on progresse c'est ça a été vite
corriger c'est pas la remise en cause on
va pas s'éterniser là dessus ça a été
corrigé simplement il ya eu besoin de
facteur de correction ce qui est
légitime
est ce que dans tous les endroits
maintenant il y aura plus ce type de
problème simplement voilà c'est pas de
dénoncer quoi que ce soit c'est pas vous
alors si vous avez pris des mesures s'il
y en a eu
écoutez bon on peut pas remettre en
cause et témoignages qu'on a eu depuis
des heures et des heures d'audition nous
nous prenons acte de ces témoignages
on peut dire que tout s'est bien passé
on a constaté un nombre de morts qui
étaient quand même important en france
par rapport à d'autres pays donc on peut
se dire aussi qu'on peut peut-être
encore amélioré les choses mais je sais
que c'est votre volonté mais je ne dis
pas des mois et des mois en me donnant
les éléments factuels tout à fait et on
vous aidera à vous inquiétez pas
ah pardon sur les hôpitaux de proximité
le ségur de la santé d'abord la loi ma
santé 2022 à porter une ambition très
forte pour les hôpitaux de proximité
puisque vous savez que nous souhaitons y
rétablir et nous avons commencé à le
faire des plateaux techniques de la
biologie de l'imagerie resterait parfois
de l'activité l'activité d'urgence pour
transformer et continuer la
modernisation de ces hôpitaux qui a
commencé d'ailleurs avec marisol
touraine dans un mandat précédent et qui
avait donné un statut et un financement
pérenne à ses établissements
le ségur de la santé va plus loin et le
plan d'investissement d'ailleurs de 6
milliards d'euros plus la reprise de
dettes permettront de compléter de
conforter cette modernisation pour
restaurer au coeur de l'ensemble des
territoires y compris les moins peuplées
des hôpitaux digne de ce nom pour
accueillir les malades
merci est votre regard sur santé
publique france nous avait donné des
défait par rapport au stock à la
logistique à la distribution mais votre
regard sur santé publique france et
l'intégration de l'eprus que l'on a voté
pour un grand nombre
vous l'avez rappelé est ce que
finalement c'est une bonne chose
ou est-ce qu'il ya quelques
modifications apportées par rapport à sa
réactivité en période de crise c'était
la question de sylvie bernier
l'organisation de santé publique france
dans les territoires à mon sens
mériterait d'être ré interroger les
fameuses cyr qui sont en lien que les
ars mais qui ne sont pas sous tutelle à
proprement parler ars il faut intégrer
la recherche fondamentale la recherche
appliquée et la question logistique dans
un appareil qui soit pleinement
performant et qui pour sa dispose de
tous les outils donc dans les
territoires je pense qu'il est important
de se reposer la question et ça ira
d'ailleurs jusqu'au stock de matériel de
protection davantage territorialisée
qu'il est aujourd'hui davantage allez je
vous ai répondu sur ce point là je vous
ai dit les grandes qualités de santé
publique france pour pouvoir fournir des
données ce qu'ils fournissent d'ailleurs
toujours aujourd'hui avec je peux vous
le dire applications en précisant
certain nombre de choses parfois ça a pu
créer la confusion et j'ai pu être
amenés à le dire je vous donne un
exemple santé public français était
l'organe qui comptabilisait et publié le
nombre de tests réalisés dans notre pays
avant que nous ayons cidep santé
publique ans publié sur son site un
nombre de tests fortement sous-évalué
par rapport à la réalité
semaine après semaine et indiquait
d'ailleurs
si tu que ce nombre de tests étaient
estimées sur la base d'échantillons de
laboratoires publics et privés d'avs
publics et privés donc plusieurs fois
j'ai appelé un présent de santé publique
rend son exemple peut-être qu'au lieu de
publier des chiffres qui sont
sous-évaluées parce qu'à l'époque qu'on
me faisait reproche de ne pas attester
que les chiffres publiés tout était basé
sur ces chiffres là mais je me disais
vous savez on fait des études
statistiques on n'est pas en train de
dire qu'on est on n'est pas dans notre
rôle en colligeant la totalité des
choses on explique clairement sur nos
sites que ces tests sont sous-évalués de
fait puisque nous les établissements à
partir d'un échantillon de laboratoire
et pas de façon exhaustive nous n'avions
pas d'outil de mesure et de comptabilité
supplémentaire donc nous avons eu
énormément des changes avec santé
publique rend sur la question des
masques évidemment et d'autres questions
et je continue d'avoir des échanges avec
eux sur un certain nombre de choses
regarder mais on peut pas alors on peut
pas leur demander de faire un travail
qui soit à la fois un travail de rendre
compte à un moment donné de la situation
et dans et de modélisation et des études
épidémiologiques par anticipation un
exemple c'est lorsque vous voyez les
courbes qui sont publiés d'incidence et
que du fait des retards d'inscription
certaines données dans le cidep eh bien
on pourrait avoir faussement
l'impression qui a des incidences qui
baissent et que la situation s'améliore
mais c'était plus une france alerte là
aussi dans son bulletin en disant
attention les données ne sont pas
consolidées il faut les regarder avec
quatre ou cinq jours de recul pour avoir
véritablement l'incidence donc si vous
regardez les données brutes de espérez
vous dit et vous comparez la réalité
vous dis mais qu'est ce qu'ils font est
en réalité ils font un travail qui est
un travail sérieux sur la base des
données dont il dispose
bon est ce que on peut est-ce qu'on peut
changer les choses oui on changera des
choses je vous le dis et notamment en
matière de gestion crise mais on change
pas les choses en cours de route en tout
cas pas en profondeur parce qu'il nous
faut de la stabilité
il nous faut de la stabilité dans le
moment mais viendra l'heure de se poser
des questions et de proposer des
réorganisations la modernisation par
tous a fait partout ça fait sens
croyez moi merci bernard jomier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre a donc vous nous avez expliqué
votre stratégie
si j'ai bien compris c'est de maintenir
la circulation du virus à un niveau de
telles que l'ensemble des activités de
soins usuels puisse se poursuivre pour
ne pas pas de nouveau avoir cet effet
collatéral sur des ruptures de chaînes
de soins est donc juste une précision
pour être bien clair ça passe par
l'augmentation si nécessaire des moyens
hospitaliers à reformatage et vous avez
cité donc le chiffre d'une progression
jusqu'à quatorze mille des lits de
réanimation donc c'est juste pour être
clair si j'ai mal compris vous vous le
reprendrais mais sinon donc vous êtes
dans cet état là d'esprit maintenir
cette circulation de virus avoir une
marge supplémentaire pour augmenter si
besoin les moyens hospitaliers les
moyens de réanimation et dancette
jusqu'à cette limite là le
fonctionnement usuel des hôpitaux ne
sera enfin tom sera impactée au minimum
en tout cas il y aura pas l'impact qui a
eu au printemps j'ai quelques questions
à vous poser la première et sur la
stratégie de lutte contre l'épidémie
avec on a vu se mettre en place donc la
stratégie sur les masques sur les gestes
barrières sur la distanciation physique
et qui paraît on va dire à peu près
abouti on peut toujours en discuter des
modalités et probablement d'ailleurs
relativement efficace puisque la reprise
de circulation du virus n'a pas du tout
la cinétique qu'elle avait au printemps
et puis le deuxième pilier qui est la
stratégie tester tracé isolé le premier
ministre avait choisi protégé pour des
raisons politiques sans doute mais la
stratégie scientifique s'est testé tracé
isolé et cette stratégie là le constat
est largement partagée et documenté
qu'elle est dysfonctionnel donc je vais
pas reprendre l'ensemble des données
nous avons eu des auditions ces jours
derniers sur la question des tests des
délais pour accompli
les tests qui souvent ont dépassé et
depuis plusieurs semaines le délai de
contagiosité donc qui a impacté la
capacité du test à permettre une rupture
des chaînes de transmission conflits
donnée confirmée par la cnam qui lors
des traçages se rend compte que 80% des
personnes testées positives n'avaient
pas été identifiées comme cas contacts
donc beaucoup de chaînes de transmission
échappent à cette stratégie est dans le
volet isolement un discours qui est
parfois difficile à comprendre mais bon
parce qu'il a beaucoup bougé aussi au
fur et à mesure des connaissances jeu
notamment sur les durées d'isolement
mais qui à l'échelon individuel on va
dire et porté envers l'opinion publique
mais pour les personnes qui sont en
habitat collectif haut que et
communautaire une absence de solution
qui est proposé est donc toute cette
stratégie sur laquelle vous travaillez
actuellement sans côté dysfonctionnel et
probablement pour une large part
responsable de la reprise de circulation
du virus comment en est on arrivé là
alors qu'il n'y a plus de problème
quantitatif en termes de tests et il
faut saluer cette action là et que cette
stratégie est bien établie depuis
plusieurs mois et que la période
estivale aurait pu permettre de
l'affiner et de la mettre en oeuvre pour
éviter ces reprises question suivante il
m'en reste deux nous avons quand nous
avons auditionné au sib ndiaye elle elle
nous rappeler le constat qu'elle avait
fait quand il était membre du
gouvernement de que la demande de la
société
c'est essentiel ce que la façon dont se
comporte une société quand une épidémie
survient était une demande de
transparence et d'horizontalité hier
vous avez annoncé des décisions et on a
constaté que les élus des territoires
concernés semblait n'avoir pas été
concerté les acteurs locaux de ces
territoires
les acteurs de santé
les élus locaux les acteurs du système
médico social pourquoi n'ont pas et ils
étaient consultés en amont de l'annnonce
de ses décisions
comment est-ce que actuellement ces
concepts d'horizontalité et de
transparence sont mis en oeuvre dans la
façon dont vous élaborez vos décisions
et pour être encore plus précis au cours
des auditions
beaucoup ont mis en avant le rôle du
couple préfet maire on a tout de même un
peu le sentiment que là c'est le préfet
qui donne les ordres au maire et un
troisième membre dans le couple c'est le
ministre qui donne des instructions au
dessus et ça ça il ya quelque chose qui
n'est pas compréhensible qui provoque
beaucoup de révolte
beaucoup de colère et qui risque
d'impacter parce que c'est ça le vrai
problème on en a discuté au cours de nos
auditions avec un certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs
si les réponses autoritaires étaient les
plus efficaces du monde ma foi on est
une démocratie malgré tout mais
peut-être certains accepterait
d'entendre ce discours là mais il ya un
risque fort que ça impacte l'efficacité
des décisions qui ont été annoncées et
ça me permet d'en venir à ma dernière
question qui est la question du lien de
confiance qui est essentiel je crois
qu'on a tous été très marqués lors nos
zones aux auditions notamment du mois de
juillet où nous avons auditionné ce
qu'on appelle les acteurs de première
ligne du fait que leurs discours était
un discours de colère de colère et de
ressentiment vis-à-vis des autorités
publiques
et pourquoi ces marques ans parce que
j'allais dire et je voudrais que mes
propos je ne sois pas mal interprété
mais ce sont des acteurs qui sont des
acteurs qui sont parfaitement inséré
dans notre société
dès que ce ne sont pas des personnes qui
vivent mal l'insertion dans notre
société et qui légitimement ont un
discours vis-à-vis des institutions
comme on peut le voir qui est
systématiquement de rejet nous avons
entendu des pharmaciens des médecins des
infirmières
des aides à domiciles des professionnels
du grand âge etc
à tous nous dire qu'on ne les avait pas
respectée et qu'on les avait pas
respectées notamment parce que au moment
où il a été vive et des pénuries de
matériel des autorités ne reconnaissait
pas ne prononcez jamais ce mot de
pénurie et là la distension de ce lien
de confiance est souvent cette rupture
est extrêmement préjudiciable
préjudiciable à la façon dont notre pays
peut faire face à l'épidémie
donc monsieur le ministre est ce que
vous vivez
la rupture de ce lien de confiance est
ce que pour vous c'est un élément de
préoccupation
ce donc je ne doute pas ailleurs mais
comment comment comptez vous répondre à
cette rupture quels mots comptez vous
prononcer à quelles valeurs allaient
vous vous référez pour que dans notre
pays les institutions en charge de la
santé
les autorités politiques et l'ensemble
de la société ansamble marche et fassent
bloc dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
je remercie merci monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais commencer presque pas
répondre à votre dernière question
je joue mieux mais je vais les prendre
dans l'ordre est d'accord l'augmentation
des moyens hospitaliers je vous confirme
ce que j'ai dit nous sommes en mesure
d'augmenter si la situation était
nécessaire l'équipement lits soins
critiques et réanimation à 14000
pourvoir accueillir beaucoup de malades
au prix d'efforts considérables de thé
programmation massive de transformation
de bloc opératoire de salle de réveil en
salle de réanimation nous avons les
respirateurs nous avons les médicaments
personnel soignant est fatigué mais il
est toujours mobilisée lorsqu'on a
besoin de lui parce qu'il a une vocation
chevillée au corps et c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs fait l'honneur des soignants
dans notre pays la stratégie n'est pas
de maintenir une circulation du virus un
seul sénateur la stratégie et d'enrayer
la circulation du virus est écrasé la
circulation du virus de jeu par l'a7
était de traquer le virus plutôt que ce
soit lui qui nous traquent traquer le
virus l'affaiblir le plus possible le
mettre au niveau le plus bas possible
nous avons réussi à le faire avec des
mesures extrêmement fortes dans une
situation qui échappait à toute autre
modalité de gestion en sortie du
confinement
par contre la stratégie de réponse est
dans ce qu'on appelle les mesures de
gestion ce fameux pilier 3 comme les
restrictions de circulation les grands
les diminutions des parlers régionaux
situation et reste des réceptions de
rassemblement des grands rassemblements
jusqu'à des mesures qui peuvent toucher
les bars bars les restaurants au sein
des directions douloureuse très
douloureuse pour nous pour notre pays
pour les gens qui travaillent en s'est
mis dans ces secteurs et pour les gens
qui aiment et fréquenter ces décisions
là ils sont fondés sur le strict niveau
de pression sanitaires d'ailleurs nous
avons mis en place des indicateurs j'en
ai parlé 30 % de patients qu'aux vide en
réanimation
c'est une alerte sérieuse qui fait
basculer un territoire 60% en tout cas
en fonction de la situation territoriale
est une autre alerte sérieuse qui peut
engendrer encore d'autres types de
décisions
la pression salutaire nous n'avons
jamais opérée d'une gestion sur la base
de chiffres de courbes mais sur la base
d'une pression sanitaires alors la
pression sanitaires et dans le reflet de
l'évolution de l'incidence notamment
chez les personnes âgées
et vous imaginez que cet indicateur que
nous suivons pour pouvoir opérer quand
vous dites que le tracé tester tracé
protéger et dysfonctionnelle je n'ai pas
dit autre chose que le fait que nous
avions nous rencontrions des difficultés
importantes pour assurer aux français
qui nécessitent qui sont publics
prioritaires
l'accès aux tests dans les bons délais
vous l'avez souligné je vous en remercie
nous sommes montés même plus un million
deux cent mille mais à un million trois
cent mille tests par semaine ce sont les
chiffres que j'avais hier grâce à la
mobilisation extraordinaire de
l'ensemble des laboratoires publics et
privés qui continuent d'acheter des
machines pour faire la pcr qui continue
de commander des machines avec une
tension mondiale très forte donc les
machines n'arrive arrive encore au
compte gouttes mais on va continuer les
laboratoires s'apprêtent à faire encore
davantage de tests demain davantage ce
que j'ai dit cet été souvenez-vous gtd
je disais aux gens si vous devez vous
faire tester n'hésitez pas allez vous
faire tester on est de kun a de quoi
faire à l'époque on disait vous avez dit
monsieur ministres et sept cent mille
tests on en fait que 400 milles j mais
on est capable d'en faire est en ville
mais aujourd'hui le virus circule peu
les gens ont peu de symptômes né au
coeur de l'été et j'ai prévenu
d'ailleurs en conférence de presse avec
le premier ministre jean castex à la fin
du mois d'août que les semaines de
rentrer allez sans doute sa compagne de
tension sur l'accès aux tests sans doute
accompagner parce que les gens rentré de
congé les gens rentrés en entreprise on
leur demandait de se faire tester
parfois de façon d'ailleurs hors de
toute justification mais c'est ainsi et
puis en plus la pression sanitaires et
commence à monter et si vous faites le
calcul avec moi vous avez aujourd'hui on
connaît on avait donné sur 80% des gens
qui se font tester ses niveaux de
satisfaction de remplissage du cidep sur
ces 80 % on sait déjà qu'il ya 28 % de
patients symptomatiques
ils n'ont pas tous le coc vide mais ils
viennent avec des symptômes ou en tout
cas ils disent venir avec des symptômes
je veux dire à porter à 100% ça fait à
peu près déjà un tiers quand vous avez
un diagnostic vous avez un deux à trois
cas contacts ça veut dire que chaque
jour vous avez à peu près 35 mille
quarante mille cas contacts qui se font
tester vous ajoutez à cela une bonne
dizaine de milliers de soignants des
aides à domicile et donc vous arrivez
déjà un nombre conséquent et en fait
plus la pression salutaire montrent plus
le nom de gens positifs et qu'à
contacter montrent plus le public
prioritaire augmente donc face à cela la
priorisation qui avait été demandée au
début du mois d'août à fonctionner
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ne fonctionne plus et
c'est allé très vite
et croyez moi je le déplore c'est
pourquoi nous travaillons sans relâche
avec les agences de santé avec les
préfectures avec les laboratoires
et donc j'ai présenté les dispositions
qui sont des dispositions efficaces pour
pouvoir permettre à chacun lorsqu il le
justifie par son état de santé de
bénéficier du test sans délai c'est le
cas des barnums en ile de france ces 20
barnum qui seront capables de faire
chacun 500 tests par jour entre 8h et
14h ils sont réservés aux strictes
publics prioritaires et les laboratoires
s'engage à avoir un rendu de résultats
les 24 48 heures je lui ai dit hier soir
aussi en toute transparence devant les
français je n'ai rien à cacher monsieur
sénateurs et du coup j'ai pas grand
chose à vous apprendre que vous ne
sachiez déjà c'est que les deux tiers
des tests aujourd'hui sont rendus dans
les 48 heures à l'échelle du pays
mais là où ce n'est pas le cas là où ce
n'est pas cannes notamment dans les
métropoles notamment dit de france ces
problématiques et c'est pour ça que nous
mettons le paquet pour réduire ces files
d'attentes
est ce que c'est ça qui est responsable
de la reprise épidémique je ne le crois
pas monsieur le sénateur
je ne crois pas ce n'est pas responsable
de l'ars
prise épidémique des pays qui ont mis en
place un test est tracée isolé port du
masque systématique chez tout le monde
avec une culture de sa qui date de
plusieurs années parce qu'ils ont connu
des grandes pandémies se sont pris des
vagues épidémiques y compris au moment
où on s'y attendait pas je pense par
exemple au japon qui n'a jamais
rencontré la moindre difficulté ils sont
structurés comme ça dans le système de
santé parce qu'ils ont fait face à des
épidémies que nous n'avons pas connu et
qui font qu'ils ont fort de leur
expérience était capable de bâtir un
système quasiment infaillible et malgré
ça ces pays là ont été percutées
d'autres pays on m'a cité je crois ici
dans le sénat déjà le cas d'israël qui
était un exemple de pays qui étaient
capables de faire face aux choses très
bien mais il serait là l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle est totalement
confinés totalement confinés l'allemagne
que vous citez régulièrement comme un
exemple et vous savez sans doute raison
de le faire
l'allemagne a été la première le premier
pays européen à reconfirmer des régions
entières
alors alors même que le virus circule et
très peu en réalité le virus il a des
zones d'activités aiguë avec des
périodes épidémique plus ou moins
intenses nous travaillons pour qu'elle
soit de moins en moins 20 ans possible
avec le moins d'impacts sanitaires et
des périodes d'accalmies où les gens
sont plus vigilants moi j'ai passé mon
mois d'août monsieur le sénateur pouvez
pas dire autre chose
là c'est mon mois d'août aller dans tous
les territoires à faire des des alertes
quasi quotidiennes aux français en leur
disant qu'on avait des signes de reprise
épidémique dans les populations jeunes
notamment marseille et je vais y venir
en disant attention parce que quand le
virus circule chez les jeunes l'exemple
internationale notamment en floride et
ailleurs nous montre qui finit par
passer chez les moins jeunes et à
l'époque vous aviez des experts parmi
ceux que vous citez comme étant en
rupture de confiance avec nous qui sur
les plateaux télé disait c'est peut-être
pas mal si les jeunes se contaminent les
uns les autres agir il faut aussi se
rendre compte que un certain nombre
d'experts y compris que vous avez reçus
je ne dis pas qu'on les avait reçus avec
le tapis rouge monsieur le talent est en
jeu c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai ici
pas du tout ce que j attends d'experts
considéraient que le virus a débuté pour
être devenu moins dangereux
souvenez-vous de ce mois d'août le virus
a muté il est moins dangereux les jeunes
se contaminent pas et font pas de forme
grave
il y aura pas de deuxième vague etc etc
ce n'est pas le discours que j'ai tenu
jamais chez lui un discours d' alerte de
sensibilisation et je suis allé dans les
territoires dans lesquels le virus
circulait pour dire attention il faut
prendre maintenant les bonnes mesures
il faut prendre des mesures de gestion
parce que sinon le virus va repartir de
plus belle
il va contaminer les personnes fragiles
et on aura un impact sanitaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison de penser
qu'il est muté et c'est ainsi que je
viens au point suivant sur la
consultation la concertation avec les
élus
je vous donnais deux éléments de réponse
d'abord je considère qu'il est
fondamental d'avoir la confiance des
élus de travailler avec eux parce que
c'est difficile quand vous êtes maire
d'une grande ville
c'est très difficile et moi je vais je
vais vous je vais remercier des mères
qui correspondent à différents partis
puis vous verrez avec eux si c'est loupé
vous débrouillerez c'est pas moi je vais
remercier le maire de montpellier
michaël delafosse
j'ai remercié le maire de toulouse jean
luc moudenc
je les remercie la maire de lille
particulièrement martine aubry je vais
et je vais remercier l'ensemble des
maires monsieur guerrier le perdriau à
saint-etienne je vais remercier madame
hidalgo maire de paris je vais remercier
madame à père et maire de rennes
l'ensemble de ces mères et bien d'autres
je les ai eus au téléphone hier après
midi dans l'intervalle entre les prises
de décisions au conseil de défense et
les annonces de décisions du conseil de
défense et et l'ensemble l'ensemble
lanciers vous plaît sinon c'est monsieur
le ministre à l'ensemble de ses élus que
j'ai cités ont fait preuve d'une
réceptivité à l'égard et le maire d
écologie de grenoble erik cole et
d'autres encore l'ensemble des maires
que avec qui j'ai pu discuter en
présentant les données épidémiologiques
et les mesures en leur annonçant qu'ils
auraient une concertation avec le préfet
comme c'est la méthode pendant 48 heures
pour adapter pour adopter pour adapter
les mesures propres à chaque territoire
en fonction de la situation épidémique
je peux vous dire que je n'ai pas eu de
difficulté la situation marseille c'est
pas pour pointer du doigt des élus mais
j'ai eu c'est vrai en fin d'après-midi
le premier adjoint au maire de marseille
j'ai eu également le président de la
région de marseille
la maire de marseille je les lui la
maire de marseille j'ai dû l'appeler
même à sénatrice si vous considérez que
je dis n'importe quoi je suis sous
serment une vie ne tient qu'à vous de
d'engager la procédure qui vous plaira
sinon je continue si vous j'ai eu là
continuez monsieur
j'ai mis la maire de marseille au
téléphone plusieurs fois c'était
et que j'ai d'ailleurs moi même appelé
qui plusieurs fois m'a appelé pour que
nous échangions et je les sensibiliser
au mois d'août en lui expliquant que les
indicateurs à marseille devenait mauvais
qu'il y avait des contaminations chez un
milieu jeune qu'il y avait des soirées
qu'on me déclarait sur des ruf top alors
on a d'ailleurs été tout à fait
consciente de ça et bien et bien est
totalement en phase avec ce que je lui
disais est ce que nous échangions qui
avaient des soirées qui était notamment
sur des robes tops qui peut rassembler
plus de 1000 personnes sans masque sans
protection et que c'était dangereux pour
l'évolution de situation le nous avons
eu un conseil de défense qui a traité de
la situation marseillaise qui a proposé
la mise en place concertée entre le
préfet les élus d'un couvre-feu qui
affecterait les bars les lieux de sortie
à 11 heures du soir avec des contrôles
et c'est possible de freiner la
diffusion et de montrer aussi à la
population qu'à tension attention la
situation commençait à devenir
périlleuse je me suis rendu à marseille
le 27 août et j'ai passé je crois plus
de deux heures en préfecture de
marseille à discuter avec les
parlementaires les élus de la ville de
la métropole du département de la région
et plusieurs maires de communes
adjacentes de marseille j'ai également
rencontré la mère de marseille en
préfecture de marseille pendant plus
d'une demi-heure et des échanges que
nous avons eus nous regarde ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'à l'époque je
leur ai dit que si nous ne prenions pas
rapidement des mesures de gestion pour
enrayer la circulation du virus
il était à craindre nous soyons obligés
de prendre des mesures plus fortes plus
tard plus fort plus tard j'ai discuté
également à la suite de cela avec les
élus marseillais qui considérait que
consulter n'était pas concertés sans
doute mais qu'ont certaines ne veut pas
dire forcément tomber d'accord ça ne
veut pas dire forcément tomber d'accord
et abandonner le principe de
responsabilité il doit primer et
lorsqu'il faut protéger la vie des gens
lorsqu'il faut prendre des mesures même
difficile pour éviter que les gens qui
meurent il ya une personne sur trois en
réanimation qui a moins de 65 ans et
quand bien même il ya deux personnes sur
trois en réanimation quand plus de 65
ans ce sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
demandé à leurs animations
ce sont des personnes qui ont demandé à
être protégée et enrayer la circulation
du virus protéger les hôpitaux protéger
les réanimations protéger et soulager
les soignants vu la vague épidémique
nous avons connu dans notre pays ça me
paraît être agir en responsabilité et je
l'assumé et je l'assumerai à chaque fois
que ce sera nécessaire
on peut discuter de la qualité d'une
concertation de la rapidité monsieur le
sénateur jonnier je vous ai lu dans la
presse d'hier que le ministre la santé
et est sans arrêt en train de courir
après le virus si vous voulez que nous
ne pourrions pas après le virus monsieur
le sénateur il faut accepter l'idée que
nous soyons obligé d'acter un certain
nombre de décisions rapidement contenue
la situation sanitaire
et si à chaque fois que nous devons
prendre des décisions nous devons nous
donner des jours de discussions jusqu'à
ce qu'on arrive à tomber d'accord ou non
sur des mesures de gestion alors nous
serons véritablement en train de courir
après le virus moi je ne me laisses tu
pas de boules et les boules et c'est pas
la concertation c'est les jours de délai
entre le moment où on observe et le
moment on doit agir
j'ai entendu les critiques sur les
mesures de gestion prises soit disant
trop tard au printemps le confinement
qui était trop tard et puis le
confinement qui était trop long puis le
déconfinement qui était trop tard puis
les confinements qui était trop tôt dont
acte
quand vous parlez la confiance monsieur
le sénateur moi il ya une chose qui est
claire chez moi c'est la constance dans
le fait d'assumer les décisions de les
prendre et des mécanismes de
concertation qui font que ces décisions
sont prises sur la base de
recommandations scientifiques en conseil
de défense et de sécurité nationale sous
la responsabilité du premier ministre et
du président de la république
alors merci pour vos réponses
monsieur le ministre vous avez remarqué
tout de même que dans cette commission
denquête nous avons très peu parlé des
mois de mars avril mai parce qu'en fait
on a constaté que globalement les
pouvoirs publics avaient pris dans le
feu de l'épidémie probablement les
mesures qui s'imposaient en tout cas on
n'a pas eu des acteurs de terrain hormis
la question de cette distance avec les
responsables politiques que j'ai soulevé
et je pense que la qualité de la réponse
ne permettra pas de faire beaucoup
progressé sur les gens suis navré mais
si vous voulez que j'insiste monsieur le
ministre nous avons entendu hier deux
ministres une qui a dit le problème
c'est l'acculturation scientifique des
français mais qui ne fait aucun moment
n'a envisagé le défaut de culture de
santé publique
des responsables politiques
et de l'appareil d'état qui est quand
même aussi une question qui n'est pas
inintéressante qu'on pourrait regarder
quand même tranquillement plutôt que
dire acculturation scientifique des
français et notre ministre dont le
plaidoyer pour nous faire part de son
institution au mois de janvier était
assez convaincant et j'avais eu
l'occasion de le dire puisque vous aimez
faire référence aux propos publiques des
uns et des autres étaient assez
convaincant mais ses propos pour nous
expliquer pourquoi le le relais ne s'est
pas fait faire des décisions rapides là
n'était pas du tout convaincant et
d'ailleurs à ce sujet elle nous a
rappelé qu'on était en débat sur la loi
bioéthique
pendant qu'elle se préoccupait de
l'épidémie elle avait tout le loisir
d'en parler avec le président de la
commission des affaires sociales qui
étaient six à deux mètres d'elle donc
avec les parlementaires avec d'autres
institutions et ça n'a jamais été fait
donc on vous appelle je vous appelle
juste non pas à vous citer des tas de
personnes qui sont extérieurs qui ont
tenu des propos qui coupent qui
conviennent pas qu'ils sont des we don't
hate on n'y a eu droit ici vous en
faites pas on c'est pas parce qu'on
écoute comprend pour nous et qu'on fait
opinion de ce qui nous est dit et on
l'affrontement parfois ces derniers
jours vous l'avez vu assez assez
difficile
la question n'est pas là la question est
de comprendre une ministre a eu une
intuition juste elle comprend qu'il se
passe quelque chose pourquoi les
déceptions sont moins rapides que dans
d'autres pays
la question n'est pas de comparer point
à point la situation des pays vous
parler du japon odita où lé japon vous
allez c'est pas parce qu'ils ont bien
tester tracé isolés que l'épidémie
s'arrêter oui mais japon ils n'ont pas
fermé le restaurant non plus si on prend
point à point ces comparaisons ne valent
pas raison par contre ce que nous nous
avons fait la façon dont notre pays a
agi puis notre société c'est là où je
voulais vous interrogez parce que
évidemment vous venez nous expliquer que
vous êtes un homme engagé
engagé dans la santé publique de longue
date que vous prenez beaucoup de
dossiers où vous avez au moins d'août
compris que ça il y avait quelque chose
qui ne fonctionnait pas mais alors
pourquoi cette stratégie
vous reconnaissez quand elle est
dysfonctionnelle tester tracé isolé
pourquoi pourquoi est elle restée si
longtemps dysfonctionnelle elle est elle
encore en partie au jour d'aujourd'hui
nous voulons comprendre ces mécanismes
là c'est ce qui nous intéresse et non
pas de mettre en cause telle ou telle
personne
donc vous pouvez garder un ton mesuré
est posée ne pas vous emporter et vous
verrez on avancera sur ces questions on
ne me sûr le ministre on ne doute pas de
votre sens des responsabilités catherine
des roches
mais j'avais levé la même en fait vers
marche ni a dit parce que ma première
question c'est est quand même celle ci
agnès buzyn nous a dit que lorsqu'elle
est partie et pourquoi il ya eu un
moment ça alors c'est vrai que parmi
tous les membres du gouvernement qu'on a
reçue du gouvernement passées ou
actuelles je les dis on n'a pas eu
beaucoup d'auto critique dont je
l'entends c'est toujours difficile
lorsqu'on est un homme politique de
reconnaître des erreurs mais est ce
qu'il ya des points quand même ou en
effet par rapport à ce qu'on vient de
dire il ya eu un moment pour une raison
x ou y
un temps de latence si oui pourquoi et
comment vous souhaitez le corriger
maintenant je pense que dans votre votre
question je juste répondre sur le lac
estion de l'acculturation scientifique
cgt nahdhaouis soyez monsieur mon disque
bien qu'on s'y maintenant dans vos
réponses
les questions sont précises elles sont
précises mais j'en suis déjà à une
vingtaine de questions monsieur
sénateurs et je répondrai autant de
questions que vous le souhaiterez mais
c'est pour dire que c'est des questions
qui sont complexes
il ya une usure sondage qui est sorti il
ya quelques semaines en france
pensez vous que tel traitement soit
efficace ont de gros navires us on peut
déjà se poser la question de ce qui peut
passer par la tête d'un sondeur pour se
dire que les français ont nécessairement
un avis sur un traitement là où la
comité scientifique n'a pas forcément
postuler il y avait une quarantaine de %
de français qui considéraient que le
traitement est efficace de mémoire
autour
taj assez important qu'ils considéraient
qu'il n'était pas efficace il y avait je
crois 20 ou 22 % de français qui ont
répondu je ne sais pas je vais pas vous
faire le coup de 60 millions
d'épidémiologistes et la santé
canguilhem avait aidé y avait écrit la
santé a remplacé le salut c'est devenu
un dogme à mites c'est devenu aussi un
objet politique puissant le droit à la
santé
la nécessité de sécurité sociale et de
sécurité sanitaire ont émergé comme des
revendications politiques tout à fait
légitime
au moment où le patient se transformer
se métamorphoser en usagers de la santé
et c'est très bien c'est très bien il ya
une grande loi du 4 mars 2002 bernard
kouchner sur les droits des usagers et
des droits des patients et on assiste à
cette transformation aussi irriguées par
les réseaux sociaux par les chaînes
d'info en continu etc et on voit donc se
succéder sur l'ensemble des plateaux sur
les réseaux sur twitter énormément de
gens qui vont dire une chose et son
contraire parfois quand on a de la
chance sont pas les mêmes personnes qui
disent une chose et leur contraire d'une
journée sur l'autre par bah quand on a
moins de chance ce sont les mêmes
personnes qui sont capables de vous dire
une chose et son contraire ils sont
rarement c'est arrivé très interrogés
sur leurs propos du passé mais tout cela
je pense créé beaucoup de confusion
ça veut pas dire que la science soit
l'apanage des sachants et des
scientifiques et moi je suis médecin
comme vous me donniez et je considère
que une information doit être claire
loyale et appropriée qui doit être
comprise par les personnes donc il faut
faire en sorte qu'une information puisse
être comprise et pour cela il faut être
d'abord transparent dans les données
dans disposons pour décider ce que j'ai
fais encore hier en montrant les courbes
les anticipations les simulations les
modélisations en mettant les réserves du
sage parce que la science n'est pas
imparable et il faut expliquer prend le
temps d'expliquer leur expliquer le
pourquoi des décisions sur le sur savoir
vous me dites parfois vous avez trop
tardé à prendre des décisions
je ne suis pas là pour faire le
moratoire sur la décision n'a fait que
j'aidais prendre juste à faire le
parallèle entre ce que vous me dites est
ce que vous m'avez demandé juste
auparavant
vous décidez sans prendre le temps de
consulter les gens ou sans prendre le
temps d'avoir une vraie concertation
parfois deux jours c'est trop
parfois deux jours c'est trop tard et
lorsque vous avez des chiffres sanitaire
qui monte une pression sanitaire qui
montent deux jours deux jours ça peut
faire la différence
deux jours ça peut faire la différence
donc oui il faut répondre en urgence
j'étais neurologue en unité de soins
intensifs neurovasculaires à m'occuper
des avc à faire des thrombolyse on dit
là-bas que le temps c'est du neurone
quand j'ai commencé on disait qu'on
avait une heure trente pour thrombolysés
un malade sinon il risquait de garder un
handicap à vie physique moteurs
sensitifs ou perdre le langage
avis donc prendre des décisions dans
l'urgence les assumer et les expliquer
ça fait partie intégrante de ma
formation professionnelle de ma vocation
de médecin je l'assumé pleinement je dis
pas que c'est simple je dis que oui
parfois il faut prendre des décisions
qui sont rapides et parfois on peut pas
les prendre trop vite non plus et pour
madame de moi je pourrais faire ici la
liste intéressante des moments où j'ai
eu à a tenté par tous moyens d'accélérer
fatou moyens légaux et raisonnable
d'accélérer des processus de décision
c'est pas simple et si vous me demandez
de savoir si je suis satisfait de la
façon dont tout a roulé tout cv non nom
même de roger dumas sénatrice
évidemment que non il plein de fois où
d'ailleurs la presse s'en est fait
l'écho sur les tests salivaires sur les
tests antigénique que j'ai trouvé que
les recherches étaient trop longues ou
quand pour expérimenter un traitement
selon un protocole très célèbre
j'appelle des équipes médicales d'un
grand chu pour leur dire ce serait bien
que vous reproduisez cette
expérimentation
donc on puisse avoir des données on vous
accordera un comité de protection des
personnes acpp on vous autorise la
recherche on la finance ne vous
embarrassez pas faites nous un protocole
simple basique pour qu'on puisse avancer
et qu'au bout de deux semaines le
protocole est pas envoyer quand vous
l'envoie jeudi soir et qu'on vous dit du
coup le comité des personnes se réunira
la semaine prochaine pour statuer
non je veux vous réunissiez samedi donc
il faut réunir les gens samedi par
visioconférence parce qu'ils peuvent pas
être réunies physiquement et puis
ensuite bye à des amendements sur le
protocole et ça et finalement vous
peuvent vous prenez un mois dans la vue
évidemment que si vous me posez la
question de savoir s'il m'est arrivé
dans rage et considérant que les choses
étaient trop longues
oui je vais vous donner une anecdote et
j'arrêterai là merci monsieur une
anecdote et j'arrêterai là pour que
chacun puisse aussi lorsqu'il a fallu
qu'on a lorsqu'on a manqué découvrions
en france parce que c'est un producteur
italien qui était premier producteur
mondial et que les frontières étaient
fermés il y à une femme formidable qui
tient une entreprise familiale
dans l'heure qui s'appelle madame
lemoine avec le remercie j'ai reçu au
ministère qu'il faut avec des cotons
tiges et qui m'a dit les écouvillon
japonais fabriquent et je vais
transformer une visite de production
elle a fait son process industriel très
rapide mais comme c'est un dispositif
particulier l'écouvillon folle
stérilisait il faut que ce soit l'embout
etc
il faut forcément ça prend du temps donc
entre le moment où je manquais
découvrions pour faire des prélèvements
en france où j'avais une usine qui était
capable de produire des oeufs couvrions
mais où j'ai eu la validation définitive
que les nouveaux écouvillon pouvait
servir sur les malades
il s'est écoulé des semaines et on dit
mais c'est pas possible je préfère
encore avoir des couillons comme ça
dingue mais non parce qu'il faut quand
même des processus de validation
scientifique on fait gaffe à tous on
fait gaffe à tous quand des masques
arrivent de chine même si vous en
manquez sur le territoire voulait
distribuer pas si la douane n'a pas
vérifié que les masques sont conformes
et efficace et efficient et ça prend des
jours et ça prend des jours entre le
moment où vous décidez de quelque chose
et le moment où la chose est
opérationnel efficace ça prend des jours
nous avons un système particulièrement
normatif en france nous avons fait
sauter un paquet de normes qui était
illusoire et dérisoire pendant la
période
ml j'ai signé des décrets d arrêter à
tour de bras pour simplifier les choses
mais que voulez vous il ya des choses
qui prennent du temps je croyais moi je
le regrette
au moins autant que vous merci est-ce
qu'il faudra corriger
arrêtons d'hyper normes et dans le
processus législatif aussi à ça on va
bien c'est ce que je souhaitais et je
suis la contradiction avec la métaphore
derrière roger karoutchi
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
franchement depuis le début de ces
auditions
je me dis quand même problème
le problème n'est pas dans cette
commission denquête de dire il ya des
gouvernants qui vont être responsable et
un parlement qui veut absolument mettre
en cause de responsabilité mais
peut-être qu'on peut se dire dans un
pays où il ya déjà eu quarante mille
morts que tout le monde doit regarder un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé sincèrement
les gouvernements précédents le
parlement ont eu la responsabilité aussi
d'avoir réduit les moyens des hôpitaux
de la santé et ils doivent accepter
cette responsabilité en tirer les
conséquences pour la suite
après personne ne met en cause monsieur
le ministre votre implication elle se
voit mais je sais pas le sujet le sujet
c'est une opinion publique qui a peur
peur parce que l'épidémie reprend peur
parce que il n'y a pas de traitement
pour le moment peur parce qu'on ne sait
pas exactement quand est ce qu'on aura
le vaccin il faut à la fois la protéger
la responsabiliser et la rassurer et
pour le moment on n'y est pas vous
faites des efforts et je vais vous poser
une ou deux questions un peu précises
mais rapide pour pour être plus clair
mais on sent bien bon le débat
médiatique est ce qu'il est il est
normal tout le monde est devenu un
expert
et comme aucun des experts n'est
d'accord ça rend la situation des
français totalement anxiogène entre ceux
qui pensent que non c'est rien ceux qui
pensent qu'ils vont mourir et ceux qui
pensent qu'on n'en est pas sorti on sait
plus où on en est et la parole publique
je reprends ce que disait monsieur
daumier alors peut-être pas exactement
sur le même thème du lien sur le thème
de la crédibilité de la parole publique
moi je pense sincèrement je le dis je
les dis à dar manage les 10 aux uns aux
autres et tout le monde regarde ça mais
il eût fallu il faudrait peut-être
trouvé un moyen pour qui une unité de la
parole publique dans cette crise on ne
peut pas avoir tous les ministres aussi
sympathique soit-il ou pas qui viennent
sur les écrans télé racontaient leur
vision de la crise
le ministre de la santé devrait être
comme dans d'autres pays pratiquement le
seul chargé de dire un certain nombre de
choses d'annoncer un certain nombre de
choses parce que c'est celui qui
logiquement doit gérer la crise
sanitaire
la dispersion de la parole publique et
la dispersion de la parole scientifique
rendent le climat extrêmement petits aux
jeunes après il ya vous l'avais dit la
transparence et monsieur mise à part une
ou deux questions simples vous avez dit
avant-hier de mémoire que avec 950
personnes en réanimation
nous étions à 19 % de nos capacités et
actuel mais alors j'ai un petit sujet
parce que j'ai eu une petite discussion
un peu vive avec les gens de la rs
ile-de-france qui disait la même chose
ou à peu près sur le taux à en ile de
france
cinq mille cinq cents lits de
réanimation au début de la crise en
février mars
on nous ait dit progressivement une
montée en puissance pour être me disait
ton au mois de juillet aux alentours de
dix mille et on nous avait dit qu'en
ile-de-france on était passé à peu près
de 1200 de 1300 lits de réanimation
juillet comment par exemple vos 950
personnes en réanimation peuvent faire
19% de 10000 j'ai un petit sujet c'est à
dire que un moment soit vous nous dites
voilà où on en est pour de bon et voilà
ce qui va impliquer des mesures comme la
fermeture d'établissements et ca mais il
faut qu'on comprenne j'ai entendu votre
passage à 14 milles s'il faut mobiliser
mais où en est-on réellement aujourd'hui
et on encore à 5500 et on a dix mille at
on des capacités supplémentaires
complète complete pas avec des
respirateurs d'appoint si oui on est
dans une meilleure situation et la
dramatisation a peut-être du sens pour
des mesures économiques
elle n'en a pas pour rassurer les gens
deuxième point sur les traitements on
entend tout et n'importe quoi
certains disent oui à rien vont très
bien et puis de temps en temps on a un
responsable sanitaire qui dit mais si si
ça s'est nettement améliorée sur l'autre
demandez patients parce que on a une
meilleure connaissance on a quand même
un certain nombre de médicaments ou
est-ce qu'on en ait vraiment vraiment
est ce que les gens peuvent se dire le
taux pratiquement de mortalité qu'on
aille au printemps ne peut plus être le
cas parce que on les traite mieux et
parce qu'on sait où on en est enfin
dernier élément et ce sera ma dernière
question vous avez parlé de 2 des
réserves
enfin des commandes de vaccins fait par
la france ou par la commission
européenne
mais je vois que par exemple le groupe
johnson johnson dit qu'il est nettement
plus avancé est que il avance à un point
tel que visiblement il serait peut-être
peut-être j'en sais rien en avance sur
les autres groupes sur la mise au point
du vaccin est ce que ça veut dire que en
réalité la france et placé de manière
telle ou l'union européenne sont placés
de manière telle que quel que soit le
groupe qui a le vaccin le plus sûr le
plus rapidement nous sommes dans la
phase de poules de capacité de vacciner
les français
ou bien est ce que nous attendons les
vaccins des groupes à qui nous avons
commandé même s'ils sont en retard merci
olivier henno et merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre on a vécu
hier l'audition de madame busin est
incontestablement c'était un moment
assez fort et on a bien compris qu'il y
avait eu une intuition des plus hautes
autorités et un retard dans l'exécution
des mesures qui étaient à prendre et
elle a dit ceci il y a eu une sorte de
déni y compris dans les administrations
dans les hôpitaux
chez les médecins notre société n'a pas
cru qu'on pouvait mourir en france
est-ce que lorsque vous avez pris et
puis après on s'interroge aussi sur le
périmètre de ce déni elle n'a pas abordé
cette question naturellement m'enfin
nous on s'interroge sur le périmètre du
déni jusqu'à quel niveau il ya une forme
de déni et est-ce que vous lorsque vous
avez pris vos fonctions vous avez
ressenti le même déni à la mi février
c'est la première question la deuxième
est et
plus technique elle concerne les tests
vous avez abordé la question de la
régulation
moi je vous interrogeait sur la notion
de souveraineté
quel est notre niveau dépendance
vis-à-vis de l'asie sur ces tests et
aussi sur la question des prix puisque
lorsqu'on compare il semble qu'il ya une
différence de prix à l'intérieur de
l'europe entre le prix du test ici en
france et ce qui se passe en espagne
on est presque à 50 % de différence
est-ce que vous avez une explication sur
cette différence et je vous remercie
merci jean sol c'est le président
monsieur le ministre je salue tout
d'abord l'hommage que vous venez de
rendre à la communauté hospitalière aux
équipes médicales et paramédicales qui
n'ont pas toujours étaient jusque-là
reconnus à leur juste valeur en tout cas
c'est mon point de vue est accompagné
dans leurs attentes légitimes en termes
notamment de moyens humains et
logistiques ce le ministre vous êtes
sous serment le 26 février le match
olympique lyonnais juventus deux tours
ans de turin pardon céder roues s'est
déroulé à lyon
3000 supporters débarque d'italie au
moment où l'italie devient le pays
d'europe le plus contaminé on
coronavirus pourquoi avez-vous donc
autorisé cette rencontre ou sinon qui
vous a poussé à autoriser cette
rencontre je vous remercie
merci à l'angel préville merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre alors
moi je vais revenir sur la stratégie de
lutte contre l'épidémie
et comme vous l'avez dit une information
doit être comprise
je vais revenir sur le nombre de décès
en ehpad
/ concernant donc les personnes âgées et
qui visiblement n'a pas été la priorité
absolue de la france
dès lors qu'on a isolé les ehpad
cet isolement pour être efficace aurait
dû inclure un des consignes notamment et
cela va du cuisinier qui opère dans la
cuisine des ehpad jusqu aux livreurs
or ces personnes là n'ont pas reçu des
consignes d'être protégé et donc il
s'est produit ce qui devait se produire
c'est à dire que le virus est entré dans
les ehpad et pour mon département et
pour mon territoire qui a été très peu
touchée c'est le département du lot dans
ma commune la commune limitrophe et deux
des autres établissements très proche de
ma commune la moitié des résidants
étaient kovy de plus donc on peut se
réinterroger sur les consignes c'est
vrai d'isolement était sans doute une
bonne chose mais ça devait s'assortir
bien évidemment d'une consigne claire
alors ma question c'est quelles étaient
les consignes comment elles sont
parvenues aux directeurs des
établissements et caen l'a publiquement
vous avez annoncé que les ehpad allait
être isolé est ce qu'il ne fallait pas
dire immédiatement pour que ce soit
clair pour tout le monde que toute
personne qui aurait à faire avec les
ehpad devraient être protégés voilà
c'est ma question
merci merci victor gsma et on arrêtera
là pour la première salle
merci victoire oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre hongrois de loupe la situation
critique
nous sommes dans le rouge ans après la
guyane et mayotte qui s'en sont sorties
plus ou moins aujourd'hui la situation
est dramatique
alors il y a plusieurs niveaux de
questions j'en aurai 3
la première celle aucune alarme du
directeur général monsieur gérant
cotellon un directeur général du chu qui
se cherche qui avait déjà des
difficultés depuis son incendie mais se
sait agir est encore là
l'hôpital principal et c'est pour le
j'ai acheté hôpital ressources
pourtant il ya des comités des comités
de suivi qui se tiennent avec monsieur
le préfet où il y a les élus et toutes
les strates son invité et le directeur
général
d'après les informations que nous avons
une n'était pas forcément invité
d'autre part nous sommes maintenant dans
une situation très grave et les moyens
manquent alors qu'il y avait déjà des
difficultés à la fois structurelle des
différentes carences au niveau des
équipements vous le saviez pas ce que
plusieurs phrases madame votre
prédécesseur s'est déplacé ces derniers
temps fait pendant qu'elle est en
fonction est la situation aujourd'hui
n'a pas tellement évolué ici même il ya
deux jours la ministre des armées a fait
un certain nombre d'annoncés et de
propositions qu'elle ferait pour le
corps pour le conseil de désarmer
défensivement je souhaiterais savoir
monsieur le ministre si les mesures que
vous avez annoncé vous monsieur le
premier ministre sont en cohérence avec
les réels besoins de ce territoire
il y a eu certes des annonces concernant
l'envoi de personnels des armées
le personnel médico peut-être aussi
paramédicaux je n'ai pas le détail mais
est-ce que la fermeture des bars et des
restaurants vous semble une réponse
pertinente compte tenu de la situation à
la fois des professionnels qui sont
épuisés mais aussi des personnes
contactent des personnes malades pour la
plupart aujourd'hui d'après les
informations que j'ai est ce que la
plateforme de biologie pour les antilles
qui est un projet qui n'est toujours pas
abouti et qui devait déjà aboutir et les
limites des moyens que la rs met à
disposition du chu en particulier et des
hôpitaux de façon générale n'explique
pas aussi les difficultés et n'amplifie
pas les difficultés qui sont déjà quand
même assez important
alors monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais vraiment savoir quelles
sont les mesures que vous comptez
prendre à partir de maintenant pour que
à la fois les mesures
en techniques médico techniques et
médicales soient prises en compte
pourquoi le directeur du chu soit
également impliqué dans toutes les
décisions qui concernent le territoire
parce qu'en tant que chef de file pour
les jets acheter je crois qu'ils
devraient être impliqués dans les
comités de suivi
parce que les maires ou leurs
représentants le conseil départemental
le conseil régional et tous les
parlementaires et participe en fonction
de leurs disponibilités respectives
évidemment et c'est vraiment dommage que
contrairement à ce qui vient d'être dit
concernant les élus ici les élus sont en
première ligne et le directeur du chic
et à la responsabilité eh bien il n'est
pas forcément suffisamment écoutés et
entendus et c'est que son communiqué
qu'il a rendu public et vous avez sans
doute lu les remontées de ce communiqué
qui était quand même assez assez dur
parce que quand on est directeur général
de l'hôpital et qu'on écrit tout cela
c'est qu'on a quand même pour la patate
si je peux me permettre de le dire je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre c'est un bien
monsieur sénateurs karoutchi merci pour
vos provocations d'abord dire qu'apple
quarante mille morts mais 31 mille morts
40000 31000 vous savez que la france
dispose de données qu'on appelle les
données insee sur la surmortalité
observée une année par rapport aux
années précédentes nous avions déclaré
trente mille morts à l'époque ça faisait
15 jours que les gazettes se faisait
l'écho de mort caché à domicile on avait
même vu des études faites par je ne sais
quelle structure 10 ans qui avait dix
mille morts caché à l'hôpital c'est à
des courses quand vous comparez la
mortalité sur le l'année sur la période
de la première vague versus la même
période
les années précédentes on aurait dû
attendre à ce qu'ils aient 20 ou 25
mille morts et nous en avons déclaré 30
donc ça veut dire que non seulement il
n'y a pas une mort caché mais
probablement qu'un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont décédées
porteur du coc vie ne sont pas
nécessairement des cd du coc vide bien
premier point et c'est important parce
que je pense que si on avait dû comme
certains pays voisins rajouté 15 mille
morts du jour au lendemain je pense à
nos amis anglais notamment
je pense que ça aurait été plus
compliqué devant vous aujourd'hui de
justifier
950 passion en réa vous avez
parfaitement raison monsieur le sénateur
ça ne correspond pas à 19 % du nombre de
lits maximum armée qu'on peut avoir dans
les hôpitaux mais ça correspond
effectivement bien à 19 % des lits
actuellement armés ce que j'ai dit en
préambule et qui est fondamental c'est
qu'à chaque fois que vous armer un lit
de réanimation vous désarmer un bloc
opératoire vous annulez des chirurgie
cancérologique vous annulez de la greffe
vous annulez de la chirurgie
orthopédique vous annulez des stents
coronariens vous annulé toute cette
activité règle est indispensable pour la
santé de celles et ceux de nos
concitoyens qui n'ont pas le coc vide et
donc ce n'est pas parce que je dis que
nous serions capables si la situation
l'exigeait et je touche le bois du sénat
pour que ça n'arrive évidemment pas nous
serions capables d'augmenter fortement
le nombre de lits que nous avons envie
d'augmenter le nombre de lits donc plus
nous a plu nous mettons la pression sur
le virus pour qu'il se réduise - nous
prenons de risque de se mouvoir obligé
de recommencer a appelé des gens qui
sont en difficultés sanitaires pour leur
dire qu'on peut pas s'occuper d'eux
parce qu'il faut prioriser les comprenez
on tient compte du taux d'occupation des
réa normal si la situation ne l'exigé
onfray ce qu'on a fait dans la foi on
augmenterait nombreux vers le traitement
c'est la dexaméthasone qui aujourd'hui
le traitement qui fonctionne en tout cas
qui apporte un une plus-value s'étend en
pratique courante dans tous les hôpitaux
français toutes les équipes l'utilisent
c'est des recommandations
internationales
c'est un usage courant pape attention
pas chez n'importe quel cas qu'ovide jeu
demain le coc vis de ce que j'espère pas
avec les 38 de fièvre une petite où je
peux pas prendre ce médicament par
contre si je suis hospitalisée avec les
équipes considère que mon état justifie
ce dérivé de la cortisone bien connu pas
cher et dont on a des stocks
ils peuvent le ils peuvent me le donner
et ça réduit les cas graves
ça réduit la mortalité et ça réduit la
durée de séjour en réa ce qui est aussi
important parce que durée s'est jouée en
réa quand on les réduit bas ça augmente
aussi
actuellement les capacités de
réanimation et l'autre traitement dont
on nous dit les réanimateurs nous disent
que maintenant ils ont la pratique
courante c'est l'oxygène à très très
très haut débit c'est à dire 50 litres
minute par des nues par directement dans
le nez ce qui évite d'avoir à un tube et
les gens et de les mettre en commun
parce que l'incubation sur des poumons
fragilisé par le virus créé des lésions
respira
voir et des voies aériennes qui peut
entraîner des séquelles et aggraver
encore les choses donc on réduit en fait
le nom de malades intubés et on réduit
les durées de ré a par contre du coup le
recours aux lits d'hospitalisation non
réa est plus important que court la
première vague les gens ivres au moins
réaliser non plus à l'hôpital donc on
fait très attention aussi à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas une pression trop forte sur le
capacité en lits d'hospitalisation
conventionnel quant au vaccin
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure c'est la
commission européenne maintenant avec
des experts de tous les pays
en indépendance évidemment vis-à-vis dès
l'origine des laboratoires dont il
s'occupe qui travaille avec chaque labo
qui est en avance de phase pour pouvoir
faire ce qu'on appelle des engagements
de précommande converti en précommande
converti en commandes lorsque la
situation le nécessite
je suis tel chiffre de 300 millions de
doses par exemple pour le vaccin
astrazeneca qui était passé en pré
commande par la commission européenne
souhaite le calcul ça fait beaucoup de
doses et ça permet de couvrir donc on
s'est vraiment il ya un travail qui est
mené qui conduit extrêmement attentifs
et je pense que cette ce travail doit se
jouer à l'échelle européenne je pense
que ça fait sens vous en conviendrez
et en plus ça nous rend plus puissant au
moment de contractualiser à la fois sur
les négociations de prix et la fois sur
la capacité à garantir l'accès précoce
au marché européen pour monsieur le
sénateur ça répond pas à la question si
je voulais répondre à votre question
mais vous me citer un laboratoire en
particulier monsieur le sénateur c'est
non mais leur laboratoire johnson
johnson fait partie des 18 joueuses 20
laboratoires qui ont un vaccin un projet
d'étude
il est très certainement rien que la
commission européenne au même titre que
n'importe quel beau finalement delà des
seuls laboratoires qui ne produit pas de
vaccin c'est un laboratoire dont on dit
que si nous n'utilisons pas un certain
traitement c'est pour favoriser de
laboratoire bref passons le pour le
sénateur hainaut il n'y a pas eu de déni
monsieur le sénateur en tout cas pas
plus dans ce qui me concerne quand ce
qui concerne l'après nécessaire je
prends mes fonctions un lundi matin j'ai
fait la passation de pouvoirs à 10
heures j'enchaîne avec une réunion avec
le premier ministre qui m'accueille et
nous parlons beaucoup de l'épidémie
quel est ce n'est pas la question de
monsieur innova j'ai alors je parviens
je n'avais pas est ce qu'il y aura des
nids dans le pays voilà c'est ça c'est
ce que c'est ce que disait non mais
c'est pas moi qui le dit d'ailleurs ces
limbes usa inde accord est ce qu'il ya
eu un déni dans le pays
c'est une menace devient réel
lorsqu'elle est aux portes ou
lorsqu'elle frappe est ce qu'il ya eu un
déni d'un pays moi je pourrais vous dire
qu'il ya presque une forme de déni pas
de tout le pays mais d'une partie du
pays il y encore trois semaines dans
notre pays j'ai dire j'ai passé mon
temps encore une fois je le redis mais
c'est important
j'ai passé une mois d'août et le début
du mois de septembre a expliqué qu'il
n'y avait pas de raison de penser que le
virus ait décidé tout d'un coup de faire
ce que les virus ne font jamais c'est à
dire perdre en dangerosité vis-à-vis de
son hôte et que c'est pas parce que les
jeunes se contaminaient c'est parce que
les jeunes étaient beaucoup dont il
était nombreuse contaminé qu'elle est
moins d'hospitalisations mais que les
jeunes à les contaminés les moins jeunes
et qu'il y aurait autant
d'hospitalisation monsieur le sénateur
noblesse juge de regarder les les presse
on reste on reste dans une forme de on
n'a pas parlé de hormis il parle il
parle et dont le visuel s'il ya
peut-être une forme de pensée magique
qui fait qu'on a n'a rien on est à la
fois dans un effort de résidences
collectives qui est intense les gens
n'ont pas pu enterrer leurs morts en
famille
des gens ont perdu leur emploi les
enfants ne sont pas allés à l'école des
gens ont perdu des proches
les soignants sont épuisés et notre
système a été mis à rude épreuve comme
jamais dans notre histoire en tout cas
pas de mon vivant
donc il ya ce travail de résidences
collectives on n'a plus envie de
l'épidémie moi pas plus que vous et pas
plus que n'importe quel français en
nordic ça s'arrête
et donc quand on voit que les
indicateurs sont meilleurs qu'on est en
train de passer à autre chose que c'est
la période estivale et plusieurs fois je
les dis d'ailleurs cet été je comprends
le désir des jeunes de retrouver une vie
d'hier les jeunes pardon je m'associe
aux jeunes 40 ans mais je me mets dans
cette génération y
factuellement j'y suis qui a connu la
pandémie qui a connu les attentats
terroristes qui connaît le réchauffement
climatique le chômage de masse et la
crise économique
c'est lourd donc moi j'ai jamais voulu
être dans une position paternaliste ou
moralisatrice ou hyper hygiéniste juste
sensibiliser en disant ne croyez pas que
c'est sans danger
ne croyez pas que c'est en danger est ce
que disait hier soir on ferait un petit
effort chacun d'entre nous
supplémentaires un petit effort
au lieu de recevoir quinze copains à la
maison ben on va recevoir cinq ou six et
si on a vu cinq ou six copains dans un
bar cette semaine
eh ben on va pas revoir cinq ou six
différents lendemain c'est comme ça
qu'ils circulent
russes et on fait attention et qu'une
fois qu'on a mis le masque au sénat dans
l'hémicycle et qu'on le met dans la
voiture ou dans le métro pour retourner
chez soi
si chez soi on accueille dix amis pour
faire un pour faire un déjeuner certes
pendant pendant qu'on mange on enlève
mais quand on est comme ça on se prend
pas dans les bras on serre pas la main
etc
et ça les français sont très
majoritaires à l'avoir compris mais on a
vu des scènes y compris d'ailleurs dans
des villes qui sont pourtant en
situation d' alerte d'effusion de joie
pour des matchs de foot ou autres ou les
gens ne sont sans distance viendra
chaque fois que je vois ça je je je
souffre parce que je vois le j'imagine
la diffusion et transpire du russe bref
pardon je digresse pardon je dirais donc
vous partagez cette notion un peu de
noms je dirais pas que c'est sabatini
parce que c'est le déni c'est quand on
veut pas c'est presque psychologique
c'est pas un délit
voilà bien la question de la
souveraineté on n'est pas on n'est pas
indépendance totale vis-à-vis de l'asie
pour les tests parce qu'on a des grands
fabricants de produits notamment à nos
portes et même en france par contre pour
les médicaments oui monsieur nono
sénateurs est totalement dépendant de
l'étranger
on est dépendant pour les chaînes de
fabrication on est dépendant pour les
pour les matières premières à plus de
90% de quelques pays
c'est dangereux c'est irresponsable il
responsable que la france soit
totalement des partis et l'europe se
soient départis de capacité de
production de chose qui sauve des vies
je le dis c'est pas d'aujourd'hui ni
d'hier c'est pas votre faute ni la
mienne ça fait des années voire des
décennies
cet irresponsable nous devons retrouver
la souveraineté européenne pour tout ce
qui peut être indispensable pour nous
vous avez voté et je vous en remercie
l'année dernière je n'étais pas le
porter mais le rapporteur à l'assemblée
nationale
une disposition qui prévoit qu ont
obligé la bo à stocker des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur sur le
territoire européen
on va aller plus loin il faut
réindustrialiser mais ce sera pas simple
parce que quand vous aurez des sites
seveso implantés un peu partout en
europe
ce sera plus compliqué il faut le faire
sur le prix de ces tests plusieurs
choses d'abord il faut que vous sachiez
que la france ne prend en charge à 100%
sans condition et qu'on est les seuls à
le faire personne avance de frais et il
ya des pays dont la part de
remboursement par les systèmes de santé
est moins importante que ce qu'on
rembourse mais où il reste à charge
demander aux gens attention faut pas
qu'on
il faut comparer des choses qui sont
comparables par ailleurs les
laboratoires sont amenés à équiper à
s'équiper en plate forme de deux haut
débit pcr en masse on leur demande de
faire encore plus d'efforts d'acheter du
matériel etc
il est important de leur donner
l'assurance qu'ils vont pas le faire à
perte quand on leur demande d'embauché
en cdd ou en cdi des salariés pour faire
des prélèvements ou faire tourner les
bécanes
c'est important qu'ils aient de la
lisibilité sur la question qui portait
sur les moyens sur les moyens
hospitaliers ils ont été ils ont été au
delà de la crise le ségur de la santé
prévoit de remercier non seulement de
reconnaître les soignants et les
soignantes avec 1,8 milliard d'euros de
revalorisation j'ai annoncé hier en
comité de suivi de ségur que la première
tranche de 90 euros net par mois est
versée dès la fin du mois de septembre
pour les hôpitaux et les ehpad qui le
peuvent ou en octobre pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas qu'on a anticipé les mesures
ségur création de 4000 lits
supplémentaires
là où on enfermait les milliers année
après année dans notre pays et le
recrutement de 15000 soignants
supplémentaire pour faire en sorte que
les équipes ne soient pas déstabilisé
sur la question du match lyon turin
je reprends les dates du match lyon
turin d'abord je pourrais vous dire que
c'est pas la cour alors c'est dany
février oui tout à fait mais c'est pas
la compétence du ministre mais c'est de
les compétences d'un préfet de
département de faire une annulation mais
une fois qu'on s'est dit ça on sait rien
dit d'un point de vue épidémiologique
le 26 février le piémont et donc la
ville de turin ne faisait pas partie des
zones d'exposition à risque tels que
définis par santé publie france
il y avait en italie la lombardie la
vénétie et plus tard étendu au piémont
et elle emilie romagne
en outre il faut noter en france
l'absence au mois de février de
circulation active du virus
aucun cluster n'était alors signalé en
région auvergne rhône-alpes en dehors du
cluster des contamines qui était
considéré comme maîtrisé au delà
l'italie n'avait pas besoin qu'on
instaure des frontières avec elle elle
avait instauré ses propres frontières
puisqu'elle avait interdit les
circulations en dehors des territoires
concernés par la diffusion du virus
je pourrais ajouter à cela que lorsque
la question du match s'est posé il y
avait déjà un grand nombre de supporters
italiens qui étaient dans des rues des
villes françaises et que donc il aurait
été pas forcément plus sèches d'avoir
ses supporters rassemblés dans des bars
que les avoir dans une enceinte
extérieure dans un stade de foot et un
par ailleurs il n'y a pas eu de clusters
issue de cette rencontre
n'y a pas eu de diffusion du virus du
fait de ce match de football sur la
question des ehpad qui est une question
éminemment importante je ne peux pas
évidemment les s'est insinué qu'on
aurait fait moins attention ce qu'on a
fait une attention de tous les instants
aux ehpad tous les instants madame la
sénatrice le 5 mars les consignes
d'hygiène des mesures d'orientation
interne des réflexes à avoir pour la
prise en charge des résidents ayant des
signes évocateurs de qu'ovide sont
portés et les premières restrictions sur
les visites sont portés difficile d
jacob décision le 6 mars
je déclenche le plan bleu dans les ehpad
qui organise le plan de crise dans les
ehpad avec par exemple les gestes
barrière le 11 mars je suis amené à
interdire les visites des proches dans
les ehpad interdire les lits de proches
dans les ehpad le 22 mars la règle de
distribution des masques est fait et
affinés en lien avec toutes les
instances scientifiques et des
représentants du monde de la gériatrie
le 23 mars une stratégie nationale terre
de soutien aux ehpad sur la base d'un
réflexe retours d'expériences faites
dans les régions les plus touchées
étaient établis le 28 mars
je demande la limitation des
déplacements au sein des établissements
pouvant aller jusqu au confinement en
chambre sur l'appréciation de l'équipe
après avoir saisi pour cela le conseil
consultatif national d'éthique et le
conseil scientifique
le 30 mars annonce un accès prioritaire
aux tests de dépistage pour les
résidents des ehpad et les personnels au
fur et à mesure de l'augmentation des
capacités des tests conformément aux
recommandations du conseil scientifique
et le 7 avril j'ai fait un élargissement
massif de cette doctrine de dépistage
dans les ehpad
madame la sénatrice je l' ai déjà dit
humainement ça a été les décisions les
plus durs à prendre de toute la crise et
la décision de confinement en chambre
notamment gelé prise après avoir
consulté des directeurs d'ehpad et des
directeurs du groupe d'ehpad qui
disposait d'établissement dans les pays
à l'étranger qui avait connu la vague
avant nous et qui m'ont fait part de
leur retour d'expérience qui était qu
une fois que le virus rentrer ça moyen
de l'arrêter c'est d'isoler tout le
monde et donc on n'avait guère 180
cluster actif dans les ehpad encore nous
avons fait le choix de protéger sans
isoler et c'est fondamental
et donc nous apprenons de cela parce que
nous n'avons pas qu'il le syndrome de
glissement des personnes âgées en ehpad
s'accélère
encore sur la question de la guadeloupe
qui est éminemment éminemment importante
alors je suis très étonné c'est
directeur général du chu n'est pas
associée à la gestion de crise ce serait
moi je vais regarder je vous conte mais
j'ai pas vu la lettre du directeur
j'étais fière très chargé mais je vais
regarder cela et il est important que le
directeur du chu sont évidemment en
première ligne dans l'association
oui la situation sanitaire en guadeloupe
madame la sénatrice est inquiétante
elle est inquiétante c'est une des
situations les plus dégradées la plus
dégradée que nous ayons c'est aussi
inquiétant parce que il y avait su un
sujet avec saint martin avec une
porosité des frontières qui a été qui a
été plus voilà c'était plus simple enfin
on a c'est moins compliqué à gérer que
les frontières à une époque que ça peut
l'être aujourd'hui et puis des primes
sanitaires sur saint martin la
mobilisation de la réserve sanitaire est
totale depuis plusieurs semaines il ya
eu plusieurs dizaines de médecins
d'infirmiers d'être soignants
d'épidémiologistes experts qui ont été
envoyés le service de santé des armées
est pleinement mobilisé 1 er
c'est-à-dire l'hôpital militaire qui
avait été utilisé à mulhouse qui avait
été utilisé à mayotte est en route pour
la guyane à laquelle je vous parle il
arrivera le 25 mai il ya deux jours
madame par lino a dit que c'est moi je
dis quoi j'ai formulé la demande et elle
nous a dit qu'il colle iman et on aurait
eu sur la guadeloupe
probablement les moyens humains mais
qu'il n'était pas nécessaire qu'il y est
oui vous avez la preuve c'est moi il va
donc en fait vous allez vous mettre
d'accord
vous avez alors vous allez bien revenir
monsieur le ministre
pardon vous avez vous allez avoir les
moyens de le huer mer donc les moyens de
cet hôpital militaire qui sont sur place
le 25 c'est à dire nous sommes le donc
c'est demain et qui seront opérationnels
le 28 donc croyez moi nous faisons
extrêmement attention et il ya eu des
départs et des épidémies estivale en
guyane à mayotte au dos d'autres
territoires ultramarins que nous avons
réussi à enrayer à endiguer avec un
impact sanitaire en terme de mortalité
qui était bien plus faible que celui que
nous avions constaté en première vague
donc nous faisons vraiment le
le maximum pour cela il ya un dossier
qu'il ya une demande et pour le moment
s'installe alors qu'est ce qui freine
concernant la plateforme haut débit oui
concernant guadeloupe les suffisamment
préoccupante pour qu'on fasse un petit
focus dessus oui mais monsieur le
président alors concernant nous venons
d'avoir une autre réponse mais j'avais
donc j'avais justement concernant les
moyens qui étaient mobilisés à mulhouse
je lie explicitement demandé à madame la
ministre qui était il ya deux jours et
vous avez tous entendu sa réponse là
c'est plutôt rassurant les annonces de
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
d'avancé
concernant la plateforme haut débit qui
a été ce qui a été demandé à la fois par
le directeur général de du chu monsieur
côté long il ya un projet qui n'avance
pas qui est bloqué donc ça allonge en
fait les délais de rendu des analystes
compte tenu des moyens existants ne
permettent pas de prendre en charge
rapidement les personnes qui seraient
éventuellement des personnes contactent
mais aussi les personnes qui seraient
des personnes d'y entrer guillemets un
porteur sain disons dans la pose un
problème car sinon ce que je vous
propose c'est que autant tant sur la
composition de la mer qui va arriver en
guadeloupe que les moyens qui vont être
engagées que sur la situation
particulière de la plate forme haut
débit pcr pour l'hôpital de guadeloupe
je vous propose de revenir vers vous
avec les données chiffrées factuel
précise je vais à calais également ma
collègue des armées pour voir si des
choses moi je n'ai pas la main sur le
rsa jeunes devraient pas vous induire en
erreur
évidemment je vous donne les
informations dont je disposais à date
d'hier toi je vous donnera cet après
midi l'ensemble des informations
précises ça vous convient et vous les
communiquer monsieur le ministre à la
commission pour que sa figure est vu
d'un effectif bien sûr il ya aucun
problème
céline boulay sp rognées merci monsieur
le président je rejoins complètement les
positions de mon collègue roger
karoutchi
quand il parle d' importance de la
parole publique et d'uniformité de celle
ci surtout quand elle a été mise à mal
au début de la pandémie de la pandémie
par contre là je ne rejoins pas c'est
dit que l'ensemble de la population est
très inquiète parce qu'il me semble que
l'une des difficultés que vous avez à
gérer c'est qu'il ya une partie de la
population qui est inquiète et une
partie qu'il est peut-être pas assez
il ya une contradiction là-dessus d'où
l'importance de l'uniformité da parole
publique et que à chaque fois qu'une
information est donnée elle ne soit pas
trop contesté et j'en reviens au sujet
de l'acculturation des français à partir
du moment où chaque français concernés
par cette maladie
à partir du moment où on en appelle à la
responsabilité de chaque français il est
normal que chaque français aillent
chercher le niveau de connaissance qui
va l'aider à surmonter cette période qui
est somme toute assez compliqué et je
crois que la parole publique doit
composer avec ce qu'il se dit dans les
médias et ce qui se dit sur les réseaux
sociaux et la difficulté est que il y à
beaucoup d'incertitudes qui sont dites
d'où l'importance qu'il y ait cette
uniformité ça c'était une réflexion
personnelle et puis on a parlé de déni
on pourrait dire et c'est là dessus
de nombreuses minutes mais moi j'ai
trois questions assez précises
la première concerne les tests et afin
de réduire les tensions sur les ânes à
brad war n'est-il pas temps de
réinstaurer la prescription obligatoire
pour les tests pcr en encourageant
fortement la téléconsultation et avoir
une communication claire là dessus
évidemment ces tests qui sont pris en
charge à 100% par l'assurance maladie et
la téléconsultation il en a été question
dans le ségur sur la santé mais je pense
qu'il va falloir avoir une vraie
réflexion là-dessus à l'avenir parce que
c'est vraiment une valeur d'avenir et on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler
ma deuxième question concerne le niveau
de connaissances sur les séquelles des
patients qui ont déjà été atteints de
duke au vide surtout à l' amorce de
l'hiver parce que là aussi les les
informations les plus fantaisistes
parfois circulent là dessus et puis
aussi notamment sur est ce qu'il est
possible de le rattraper etc
je voudrais savoir le niveau de
connaissance parce qu'on parle des
malades qui pourraient attraper le coc
vide mais il ya aussi de nombreux
malades qu'ils ont eue et savoir comment
ça va évoluer est ce qu'ils peuvent le
leur et avoir excusé moi je vois là
j'essaie de terminer
savoir si les malades qui ont eu peuvent
leurrer à voir et j'ai une petite
question est un hangar dont connexes par
rapport à la question des tests
j'entends dire que les tests sont plus
chers en france que dans nombreux pays
européens
y at il une raison à cela est ce que
c'est vrai je crois que ça avait été
évoquée mais je voulais avoir la
précision là dessus et enfin monsieur le
ministre je voudrais savoir votre
position par rapport au télétravail est
ce que vous dites qu'il faut
l'encourager dans les entreprises et
peut-être nous les gêner nous les
parlementaires devront légiférer
là-dessus lors du plfss je ne sais pas
j'aimerais avoir votre position là
dessus je l'en remercie
merci laurence cohen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté parce que c'est toujours un
exercice difficile
personnellement je fais parti d'élus qui
ne doute absolument pas de la
mobilisation des services du ministère
et effectivement on ne peut que les
saluer pas plus d'ailleurs de votre
propre mobilisation monsieur ministre ni
celle de madame usa donc ça c'est pour
ce qui ne va pas empêcher
voilà ça c'est cette voie là non mais
c'est pour relever en lever toute
ambiguïté parce que je sens bien que
quand on en est mais un certain nombre
de critiques
ça devient très conflictuelle donc ça ne
met pas en cause
individuellement les les personnes mais
on est ici
et en cela je partage qu'elle dit roger
karoutchi
là on est en est quand même ici par
rapport à des choix politiques
un certain nombre d'entre vous incombe
et d'autres étaient antérieurs à votre
prise de fonction
et bien sûr vous ne on ne vous demande
pas de tout endosser mais est-ce qu'à la
lumière de ce que nous vivons
vous allez modifier un certain nombre de
choses parce que il y a des choses à
modifier et la première de mes questions
c'est que vous savez vraiment
pertinemment et que notre système de
santé était en tension avant cette
pandémie et singulièrement l'hôpital que
ça continue à être en tension et vous
vous le savez d'autant plus qu' il y a
eu très récemment une la démission à 6
fracassante
chef de service des urgences de kremlin
bicêtre val de marne le département je
suis l'élu le docteur maurice raphaël
qui est un homme extraordinaire qui
était en fonction depuis dix ans qui ne
comptait pas ses heures
je vous rappelle que c'est un des
services d'urgence les plus importants
de l'île de france près de soixante
mille entrées par an et je le cite tous
les matins se retrouver avec au moins
seize patients 100 lits pour les
accueillir
c'est trop j'arrête plus de dix médecins
de cette équipe ont également annoncé
leur départ
donc je parle d'aujourd'hui il a alerté
un an il a écrit et aujourd'hui dit ça
n'est plus possible
or vous nous annoncez effectivement un
certain nombre de lits armés quatorze
mille lits votre annonce en espérant que
que ça n'aille pas jusque là 1 par
rapport aux 5000 lits en réa
vous l'avez très bien dis donc avec
beaucoup de franchise pour armer des
lits en réa ont des armes d'autres lits
or là on est dans un voilà dans un dans
un glissement c'est à dire que
finalement on déshabille pierre pour
habiller paul ou voilà donc il ya une
grande inquiétude ya eu des soins qui
ont été programmés on a entendu des
personnes auditionnées éminentes qui
nous ont dit que il y avait eu des
pertes de chance pour des patients des
patients
quand victimes de cancers y compris en
cancérologie pédiatrique pas cesser ces
terribles rien que de le dire donc moi
ma question monsieur le ministre c'est
comment est-ce que aujourd'hui par à la
lumière de cette pandémie ont créé et on
donne de nouveaux moyens à l'hôpital
alors vous allez me dire mais j'ai
annoncé 15000 la création de 15 millions
parce que pour armer des lits faut du
personnel et on sait pertinemment que là
aussi ça fait défaut contenu des
politiques qui ont été menées jusqu'à
présent de restrictions budgétaires
quinze mille 15 milles
donc emplois créés mais quinze mille
emplois créés il y en a la moitié qui
sont réellement créés et la moitié qui
étaient des postes vacants
quelle mesure vous prenez vous avez
prises pour faire en sorte que ses 15000
emplois soit effectif
et pour éviter que les personnes que les
personnels soient épuisés parce que les
personnels sont à bout ils ont deux ils
ont donné vraiment beaucoup de leur
personne donc ça c'est ma première
question deuxième deuxième question il
ya beaucoup de mes collègues qui ont dit
qu'is et je partage qu'il ya une
question aussi le gouvernement a
beaucoup misé sur la communication
on a vu quand même qu'elle était très
cacophonique
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire est
qu'il n'ya pas eu le pour moi là ça
n'engage ça m'engage en tant qu' en tant
que parlementaire n'y a pas eu le
langage de vérité quand a été nécessaire
c'est-à-dire dire aux français il ya une
pénurie de masques
elle est réelle donc on agit de telle
façon notre stratégie va être d'abord
par exemple d'équiper les personnels
ensuite la population et c est pas
d'avoir ses approximations scientifique
qui du coup porte un coup après à toutes
les toutes les décisions qui sont prises
donc à la lumière de ça je voudrais vous
interroger sur le fait que vous avez
hier annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures pour protéger les personnes mais
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que ça
rentre en contradiction
outre ce que mes collègues on dit sur
l'association avec tous les élus mais ce
que vous ne pensez pas que ça rentre en
contradiction avec le fait que avec le
décret d'août qui a sorti de la liste
des personnes vulnérables qui pouvaient
prétendre au télétravail
un certain nombre de personnes victimes
de maladies comme l'obésité les maladies
cardiovasculaires etc etc
celles ci elles ont besoin d'être
protégés pourquoi elles sont sorties du
du décret troisième question c'est que
ces mesures autoritaires qui semble
autoritaire qui sont bons font appel à
la responsabilité individuelle
or on en est tous conscients et vraiment
la majorité de nos concitoyens et de nos
concitoyens pour que je le vois dans mon
département dans ma ville etc
les gestes barrière
sont plutôt adopter mais enfin après il
ya des choses qui se passent dans des
événements mais jeudi dans la vie
quotidienne on va dire les gens ont le
masque qui font attention etc etc
donc c est ce que et je pense qu'il faut
faire attention parce que on a tendance
à la tendance qui se dessine quand même
c'est aussi le risque d'avoir une
atteinte aux libertés et aux droits et
du coup ça m'amène à la question que
avait posé ma collègue madame préville
c'est à dire que moi j'ai quand même le
sentiment au niveau des ehpad avec la
situation qui s'est passé qu'à partir du
moment où une personne est en perte
d'autonomie
elle est ou alors voilà elle en perte
d'autonomie elle est très âgées etc
on lui dénie ses droits à la citoyenneté
ont choisi à sa place ça nous est venue
dans nos auditions
or il ya beaucoup de personnes en france
encore aujourd'hui et j'imagine ailleurs
qui sont pas mort du co vide mais qui
sont morts de l' isolement donc
restreindre les les droits de visite
c'est tout un à un problème
enfin la dernière question c'est
concernant le vous avez dit vous même et
je pense que vous y êtes attentif parce
que dans les mystiques vous avez réagi
positivement manque de médicaments
manquent de de réactifs et cetera il ya
une solution qu'il faut à mon avis entre
voir dès maintenant c'est pour être
indépendant au niveau de la france
créer un pôle public du médicament et de
la recherche au niveau national et au
niveau européen
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie r
c'est muriel jourda
merci monsieur le président monsieur
miss je souhaitais savoir comment était
organisé le service de veille au
ministère sur les risques pandémiques
internationaux par définition quel
personnel quel type de personnel quel
type de renseignement revue scientifique
avis de l' oms agents des ambassades
enfin vous comprenez quel est le sens de
ma question et je souhaitais savoir
également si
vous aviez analyser son efficacité au vu
de cette crise et éventuellement si vous
aviez envisagé de modifier son
fonctionnement
merci michel meunier président monsieur
le ministre moi je voudrais vous parler
du premier tour des élections
municipales et 15 mars
le samedi 14 mars le premier ministre
annonce la fermeture des bars des
restaurants et des autres commerces non
indispensables au quotidien à partir de
minuit le soir même et le 15 mars le
gouvernement ou le président de la
république c'est à vous de nous le dire
choisi de maintenir le déroulement du
premier tour des élections municipales
en faisant porter sur les mairies la
responsabilité et la maîtrise des
mesures sanitaires les conditions dans
lesquelles les opérations de
dépouillement du scrutin ont été
précisés in extremis dans le courant du
dimanche après midi sont quand même
assez rocambolesque à cette époque je
vous rappelle la dir la doctrine du port
du masque est celle selon laquelle le
masque est dédié aux soignants et donc
non obligatoire pour l'ensemble de la
population de toute façon il n'y en a
pas donc c'est le système débrouille
dans ces cas donc sont apparus dans
après le premier tour de ce scrutin
des cas et il y a même eu des décès de
scrutateurs ma question monsieur le
ministre est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire qui a présidé à la décision du
maintien du premier tour des élections
municipales
et est ce que vous avez eu un retour
d'information sur les répercussions de
cette élection
ma deuxième question elle sera aussi
comme ont posé certains collègues dont
notre rapporteur bernard jomier en lien
avec l'adhésion de nos concitoyennes et
de nos concitoyens et ce besoin de
confiance hier soir vous nous avez
communiqué à l'ensemble de la nation des
recommandations et
et dernière mesure et ce matin un
comédien français publiait sur son
compte instagram un pamphlet
humoristique mais qui disait en fin de
compte ce que certaines et certains
disent de manière beaucoup plus anonyme
et qui traduisent une certaine méfiance
ou en tout cas un retrait c'était pour
résumer si vous ne savez pas donc c'est
nicolas bedos qui dit arrêtez tous les
masques les distanciation et vivant
quitte à en mourir c'est un voilà donc
c'est pas sur la forme d'expression qui
heureusement existe mais je me dis est
ce qu'il n'ya pas dans la manière de
véhicules et les informations encore des
choses à remettre en cause ou à changer
à modifier parce que au-delà de cette
expression on sent bien que une bonne
partie des françaises et des français
n'adhèrent pas totalement aux gestes de
précaution
merci de votre aide merci monsieur le
ministre questions précises réponses
concises bien alors beaucoup de
questions ont été posées par la
sénatrice boulet et speroni il ya une
inquiétude qui est d'ailleurs ça rejoint
que la question d'un meunier la fin il
ya des inquiétudes des français qui est
partagé en fait je pense que tous les
français sont inquiets il ya ceux qui
sont plus inquiets aujourd'hui par la
crise sanitaire et ceux qui sont plus
inquiets par la crise économique sociale
qui peut les frapper et en fait je ne
sais pas quelle est la répartition ses
inquiétudes certains sont inquiet par
les deux je ne connais pas de français
qui soit objectivement inquiet par rien
dans l'appel que le connaissons et je
tiens à rassurer les français qui ne
regarderait ce n'est pas un mal français
ça touche absolument tous les pays qui
ont été concernés et qui sont concernés
par le cos vide ça remet en question
énormément de choses dans le monde près
de trois humains sur quatre ont été
confinés ce n'était jamais arrivé et
donnons perdu expertise des grandes
pandémies qui qui fracturent est qui et
qui tue donc il faut pouvoir dans cette
inquiétude dans ce contexte
d'inquiétudes partagées il faut avoir
une ligne de communication qui est clair
j'entends les critiques que vous portez
je suis désolé si la communication
gouvernementale vous a paru manquer de
clarté par endroits nous avons organisé
une communication autour du mystère la
santé des affaires sociales et des
sociétés solidarité du premier ministre
du prêt dans la république
et puis les ministres sont ont été
amenés à participer à des conférences de
presse lorsqu'il s'agissait des partis
qui concernait leur périmètre
ministériel
j'ai pas eu le sentiment en tout cas que
l'on se marcher sur les pieds des uns
les autres
en fait dans ce sujet dans ce contexte
là puisque c'était une volonté du prix
dans la république et la communication
sur la plus claire et la plus uniciste
possible poser une question qui n'a
ensuite qui n'a rien à voir qui est sur
les prescriptions obligatoire de test
est-ce que je vous pose est ce que je me
pose la question le matin en me rasant
oui je me dis oh nous avons mis en place
la des dispositifs nous avons réorienté
tous les barnums pour pouvoir faire des
tests en quantité pour tous les publics
prioritaires mais si jamais nous étions
en difficulté malgré cela et si malgré
le nom d'une façon de cas prioritaires
devenait tels que nous n'arrivions pas à
faire face à l'objectif de la réduction
des délais des lacs qui se réduisent
déjà à mon avis les premiers chiffres
seront seront de ce point de vue là bien
meilleur que les derniers les prochains
mais si jamais on devait en arriver là
oui face d'eux les pays beaucoup de pays
qui nous entourent ont été amenés à
mettre en place des systèmes de
prescription obligatoire
la seule chose mais pourrait tout à fait
transparent dans ma façon de raisonner
avec vous c'est que si je demande à
quelqu'un d'aller chez son médecin avant
d'aller faire un test
on va se prendre globalement avec les
épidémies d'e lire aussi arrive 24 à 36
heures dans la vue avant que la personne
puisse avoir son puisse commencer à
imaginer certes ester donc je vois là
j'étais sur l'efficacité
moi je concert tu consultes pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là mais je
suis s'il fallait le faire on ferait
vous me posez la création du duc au vide
au long cours j'ai déjà dit tout ce que
j'avais sur le sujet y compris non
c'était à l'assemblée nationale
pardonnez moi il ya des gens qui font
des formes graves de coville qui vont
réanimation qui ont des troubles
respiratoires avec des scanner
thoracique qui montre des lésions de
fibrose avec des séquelles respiratoires
potentiellement allons allons donc où
l'on court ces gens là sont mis en
maladie professionnelle avec un taux
d'invalidité et ils sont suivis en
pneumologie pour les séquelles des
dégâts pulmonaires et respiratoires du
virus il ya des gens qui font des formes
qui sont pas forcément grave
symptomatique en tout cas qu'ils vont
pas forcément real ou à l'hôpital et qui
conserve à l'issue de leur maladie une
fatigue des maux de tête des craintes de
courbatures parfois une perte d'appétit
des vertiges beaucoup de symptômes qui
sont difficiles à rassembler si vous une
salle étiquette mais qui sont bien
ressentie par ceux qui les ont certains
décrivent que ça peut durer deux
semaines d'autres hors de moi et
certains disent qu'ils ne les ont pas
perdu des mois après les médecins
travaillent avec la recherche et
notamment la recherche clinique pour
essayer de comprendre ce qu'elle est la
nature de ces symptômes et ce qui a pu
les provoquer j'ai vues différentes
hypothèses dans lesquelles je ne me
risquerai pas ici mais qui font l'objet
de protocoles d'étude et des filières de
prise en charge de ces patients sont
organisées dans des centres spécialisés
vont essayer d'apporter des réponses
ce que je fais c'est que ces personnes
là quand on fait des épreuves reines
fonctionnelle respiratoire lorsqu'on
fait des scanners pulmonaire ou des
examens cardiaques pouces et non pas de
cause anatomique identifiés et pour
autant ils se sentent dix pays qui
reverra donc ça fait partie des mystères
de ce virus un mystère est là pour être
élucidées je voudrais apporter une
réponse à ces personnes la plus rapide
et la plus satisfaisante possible et
trouver surtout un moyen de les soulager
à date je ne sais je ne peux pas encore
vous répondre je crois pas qu'il y ait
enfin on est très loin d'un consensus
scientifique en question les risques de
rechute manama sénatrice ce que je sais
c'est vous le savez aussi c'est qu'il
eut quelques cas qui ont été
emblématique puisqu'ils ont fait la une
de la presse scientifique mondiale de
personnes qui étaient immunisés et qui
ont pourtant rien trappe et de virus
quand quand les cas qui arrivent sont
emblématiques et que vous avez
millions et des millions de cas on peut
quand même considérer raisonnablement
qui a pas de raison de refuser le coc
vivre quand vous l'avez choper une
première fois maintenant on a peu de
recul est-ce que les anticorps ils vont
durer six mois ou un an ou deux ans j'en
sais rien je sais pas j'ai honnêtement
je ne sais pas je peux pas vous dire
toujours se méfier et la présence
d'anticorps ne signe pas forcément
défaut alors là on sait que le vote des
anticorps son protecteur mais pour vous
dire il faut pas qu'on soit trop
empressés avant de avant d'acter des
choses l'histoire du vih elle a été
marquée par cette terrible histoire des
gens chez qui on identifier des
anticorps
il était donc séropositifs et les
médecins leur disait à l'époque on
connaissait pas le sida et leur disait
vous est immunisé contre le sida alors
qu'en réalité ce que les anticorps était
malade c'est pas du tout le thé avec le
comité rassure tout le monde mais c'est
pour vous dire que le fait d'avoir des
anticorps n'est pas forcément en soit
avec si peu de recul un élément
déterminant pour la suite de sa vie mais
ça ne protège pas forcément mais on a
quand même des indices qui laissent à
penser que si plutôt optimiste
rapidement les tests sont gratuits pour
la population
encore une fois ils sont gratuits pour
tous pour la population française le
prix du test et 55 euros pour une pcr
c'est un prix qui permet aux biologistes
je l' ai déjà dit d'investir dash et des
plateformes pc r c'est normal qu'ils
aient un prix qui sinon les biologistes
ne s'équipent and n'anticipe pas ne
prévoit pas et on n'a pas assez de tests
télétravail oui oui tout à fait d'accord
et si vous voulez mener un travail des
sites hâtives sur la question ça peut
être très intéressant madame cohen le la
difficile turn over de la médecine
d'urgence déjà hors crise est compliquée
la médecine d'urgence et beaucoup de
médecins urgentistes passionné par la
profession finissent par aller faire
d'autres types d'exercice de la médecine
parce que c'est toujours les urgences
c'est dur la médecine d'urgence passer
ses nuits ses journées à chercher des
places dans les gérer le stress parfois
se sentir pas forcément sécurité avec
une telle polyvalence et un tel nombre
de patients je me souviens des dernières
garde aux urgences comme jeune médecin
ou de confier à 18h la ligue d'été j'ai
pas des vingt patients dont je devais
déjà occupé avec un nouveau patient car
toutes les cinq minutes
c'est un métier stressant oui mais les
questions étaient je vien répondre plus
rapidement à cliquez sur mon été posés
les uns
minutes j'en suis à une minute de
réponse les années d'or passionne mais
être nous pourrions répondre os que le
ségur le ségur soutien très fortement
l'hôpital et vous aurez l'occasion d'en
plfss de voter des mesures de soutien
des créations de postes écrit
d'ouverture de lits des réouvertures de
lit la reprise de dettes de
l'investissement hospitalier et 8
milliards d'euros versés aux salariés
dont 80 et quelques pour cent sont des
femmes sous payés pour le boulot qu'elle
faisait et vous allez j'espère et j'en
suis certain voter ces mesures
au moins 7,6 dans le plfss sur la
pénurie vis-à-vis de la doctrine là je
veux bien répondre 30 secondes mais vous
allez me reposer la question si je
réponds 30 secondes monsieur le vice
président sur la pénurie versus doctrine
des masques je ne fais pas de lien entre
la pénurie de masques et la doctrine
d'utilisation des masques je lui ai déjà
dit je le redis je ne fais pas le lien
le cdc européenne n'avait pas gérer des
stocks de masques n'a pas fait le lien
non plus qui a fait la même doctrine
l'om est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas à gérer
le stock de masques à fait la même
doctrine
si je reprends deux secondes mais vous
connaissez ça presque mieux que moi si
ce n'est mieux parce que vous avez posé
la question à tout le monde mais le ms
quand même le 6 avril 2020 alors qu'on
produisait déjà des masques grand public
dans ses orientations provisoire le ms
des conseillers encore le 6 avril 2020
des conseillers expressément le port
généralisé du masque considérant que
c'est contreproductif
je décide aucune donnée ne montre
actuellement le port du masque pour les
personnes en bonne santé et dans les
espaces collectifs y compris s'il est
généralisé pour prévenir les infections
par des virus respiratoires
le port du masque médical dans les
espaces collectifs peut créer un faux
sentiment de sécurité est amené à
négliger d'autres mesures essentielles
comme jet des mains etc et c'est ce que
j'ai répété à l'envi j'ai répété ça à
l'envi les recommandations de m s les
recommandations de ces décès les
recommandations de toutes les instances
scientifiques dont on dispose et tous
les vieux grimoire de mystère la santé
qui regorge d'études sur la grippe et
sur la grippe h1n1 entre 2009 et 2020
porté vers la même doctrine donc je le
dis très clairement je suis arrivé comme
ministre il n'y avait plus
le mal était fait en matière de stocks
de masques si j'avais dû dire aux
français on aurait dû vous donner des
masses ne m'a pas je leur ai dit il ya
deux choses qui sont différentes la
doctrine et le et le stock en
l'occurrence on n'avait pas un stock
suffisant ne serait ce que pour protéger
les soignants je leur ai dit je l'aurais
dit sur la doctrine
elle est inspirée je vous le disais des
recommandations scientifiques françaises
européennes et internationales oms et
nous avons évolué avant que celle ci
évolue parce que le msm du temps pour
bouger c'était je crois le 4 ou 5 juin
colomès a considéré que le masque grand
public pouvait s'en faire consensus
scientifique être intéressant c'était
très longtemps belle lurette qu'on
produisait des masques les masques grand
public je comprends parfaitement je veux
pas donner l'impression d'être au dessus
de la polémique je comprends
parfaitement et je vous assure que j'ai
vécu la crise et des traversées avec ce
sujet là en permanence
est ce que je regrette qu'on n'ait pas
eu les stocks de masques suffisant pour
protéger les soignants les hôpitaux les
médecins etc
ah oui évidemment évidemment est ce que
si j'avais eu 2 milliard de masques en
stock on en aurait distribué à la
population jeu honnêtement sur la base
des recommandations dont on dispose je
ne vois pas pourquoi on le fait par
exemple on avait des gants on aurait pu
distribuer des gangs
on savait pas on n'avait pas la
conviction que le gore n'était pas a
priori le grand débat protecteur et de
fait le gain des protecteurs mais
imaginons qu'on soit rendu compte en
cours de la crise que le gant était
protecteur nous auriez dit pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas disposer des gants on sait
qu'un outil est utile lorsqu'on a prouvé
son utilité
jusqu'à preuve du contraire n'est pas de
passage aérosols du virus coronavirus ce
que nous disaient tous les scientifiques
du monde entier et donc le port du
masque en population générale ne
s'imposait pas elle n'était même pas
forcément recommandé d'après les records
de la chaise et j'ai dit d'ailleurs même
très très tôt je crois ma deuxième
conférence de presse qu'il aurait une
utilité si au moins 60% de la population
le porte est continuellement et la bonne
manière voilà par ailleurs encore une
fois ça ne change rien au fait qu'on
n'avait pas assez de masque pour
protéger correctement les soignants dans
les hôpitaux en ville et que ça ça
c'était extrême extrêmement dur à gérer
si je le dis aussi aussi jeudi m
de gestion en bon père de famille pour
éviter de tomber à zéro au niveau des
stocks vont poser la question du décret
sur les personnes vulnérables
ce décret vise à éviter avant tout la
désinsertion professionnelle de
plusieurs millions de personnes qui sont
en qui étaient en activité partielle
depuis des mois il y a un avis du haut
conseil de santé publique du 19 juin qui
autorise la fin de l'activité partielle
prévue au 1er septembre
on peut faire évoluer les choses en
fonction de la circulation du virus
évidemment que la priorité reste la
protection des plus fragiles
mais ce risque de désinsertion
professionnelle est réel j'ai concertée
moi même les fédérations d'usagé et pour
pouvoir déterminer aussi avec eux des
listes de maladies donnant lieu à la la
mise en activité partielle persistante
est par ailleurs un médecin peut sur
ordonnance continue de déclarer son
patient comme étant trop trop à risque
pour aller au travail et en favorite le
télétravail dans tous les cas problème
jourdain l'organisation de la veille
sanitaire
pardon jours de l'as partant journée à
pardon même jourda madame la sénatrice
par d'autres aux sur la question sur la
question expertise sanitaire
le corus qui est le cellule en charge ce
qu'on appelle c'est le centre
opérationnel chargé de la réception la
gestion des alertes sanitaires et la
coordination des acteurs de l' expertise
sanitaire est certifiée iso
il a une composition je peux vous donner
dans le détail peut-être pas là parce
que sinon je me fait rappeler à juste
titre à l'ordre mais vous avez beaucoup
de partenaires qui sont également
mobilisés au delà du au delà du chorus
de la sous direction il ya les ars et l'
agence de sécurité sanitaire nationale
comme la rsm le ffs agence de
biomédecine l'acalan 16 lire et celles
dont vous avez tout une sorte un panel à
une flopée d'agencés de structures qui
participent à la veille et la sécurité
sanitaire par catégorie par spécificité
comportant les meilleurs experts
est ce que il faut changer cette
organisation de la veille sanitaire je
crois qu'elle a fonctionné contamines
montjoie l'oise des choses qui ont été
identifiés tout de suite très vite donc
elle a pu montrer qu'elles étaient
fonctionnels mais ça fera partie dure et
ex général de toute façon sur les
municipales premier tour des municipales
qui a décidé c'est le politique qui
décide jamais on n'est pas dans un bio
pouvoir
toute décision a été prise par les
responsables politiques
le conseil scientifique a été consulté
deux fois le 12 mars et le 14 mars les
deux avis son public
je peux vous dire sous serment que face
aux conseils scientifiques
je leur ai dit la phrase suivante
l'internât lisez pas la contrainte
politique ne vous préoccupez pas de
savoir si c'est compliqué ou non
d'annuler une élection est-ce que
l'annulation du premier tour de
l'élection municipale vous semble
nécessaire utile ou non le 12 mars la
vie dit il faut pas annuler les
élections le 14 mars
deux jours plus tard je redemande compte
tenu de l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire
la réponse du conseil scientifique et la
même deux points ouvrez les guillemets
l'exercice de la démocratie garantie par
la sécurité sanitaire du vote gagne à
être préservé afin que la population
conserve dans la durée une confiance
les élections du premier tour des
municipales se sont déroulées dans des
conditions particulières avec de la
distanciation sociale respect des gestes
barrières gels hydroalcooliques stylos
etc etc du des études intéressantes qui
n'ont pas montré me semble-t-il mais je
suis sous serment donc le me semble-t-il
je n'aime pas le prononcer mais qu' il
n'y avait pas eu un très fort en tout
cas il n'y avait pas eu un impact
mesurable à la suite à la suite de cela
les scientifiques dans les haines dans
les mois qui viendront publieront des
données je pense plus affiné sur sur sur
la question
et puis sur le granth sujet presque
philosophique de savoir s'il faut vivre
qui tarde mourir si c'était je pourrais
comprendre ce type de réflexion celle
importée des conséquences sur sa seule
santé moi je ne peux pas imposer aux
gens de prendre soin d'eux malgré eux
mais on peut imposer aux gens de prendre
soin des autres
malgré la ceinture de sécurité dans une
voiture n'a pas que pour but de protéger
le conducteur
elle a pour but aussi de protéger les
autres l'hygiénisme est une discipline
complexe qui est peuplé de mise en garde
d'injonction relisez camus
disait camus on n'a rien inventé le
confinement d'oran le lassitude qui
gagne la population semaine après
semaine mois après mois
c'est la tentation de certains de se
dire et puis tant pis et puis certains
commencent à dire que finalement c'est
des personnes âgées que c'est peut-être
moins grave on n'est pas dans soleil
vert on est dans la société française on
est dans le pays des lumières on protège
les gens qui sont vulnérables
peu importe leur âge peu importe les
facteurs de risques sanitaires qu'ils
ont ce n'est pas à nous ce n'est pas à
moi de décider qui mérite d'être protégé
et qui peut mourir pour protéger les
autres c'est je veux dire c'est une
question qui est essentiel nous avons
fait le choix le président de la
république a été très clair avec le quoi
qu'il en coûte de protéger la vie et
d'assurer la sécurité des français
et j'ajoute pour ce qui serait réservé
sur la question d'intergénérationnel it
est question à laquelle je crois
fondamentalement sinon je n'aurais pas
fait de la neurologie il n'avait pas
commencé ma carrière en travaillant en
ehpad comme aide-soignant j'ajoute que
par est un malade qui n'a pas même pas
65 ans
donc voilà vivre quitte à en mourir
c'est une phrase à l'emporte-pièce qu'on
peut lancer sur un blog sur un compte
instagram
on peut faire un effet de tribune où
c'est peut-être une façon un exutoire
personnel je pense que dans la période
on doit être extrêmement attentifs
surtout quand on est on fait on a
beaucoup d coûte autour de soi à notre
façon à nous exprimer et aux messages
que nous véhiculons une société qui
déciderait de faire l'impasse sur ces
vieux une société qui déciderait de
faire l'impasse sur ces fragiles sur ces
précaires et de faire l'impasse sur des
morts évitables
ce n'est pas une société dans laquelle
j'ai été éduqué élevé et dans laquelle
j'ai envie de d'éduquer mes enfants
merci jean françois rapin
mais je le président merci monsieur le
ministre vous avez votre expérience de
neurologues j'ai mon expérience de
médecin généraliste et je vais vous
poser plusieurs questions je suis sur la
pratique actuelle on voit pas trop
revenir enfin j'y reviendrai un petit
peu sur sur l'antériorité mais en tout
cas sur l'actuelle vous avez annoncé à
plusieurs reprises et on l'a entendu un
objectif alors je ne sais pas si tu as
un objectif mais on entendait
régulièrement le chiffre de 700 mille
tests par semaine qui est peut-être un
chiffre d'efficacité qui est un chiffre
peut-être aussi de capacité d'absorption
des tests en tout cas aujourd'hui on est
à un million 101 millions 2 en fonction
des semis en trois mêmes ça monte encore
donc je voudrais savoir d'abord si le
chiffre de 700 milles pour vous était un
chiffre scientifique ou un chiffre
technique par rapport à la capacité
d'absorption et la façon dont
aujourd'hui on pourrait résorber
finalement cet excédent parce que 6 700
milles était chiffres de capacité
d'absorption passé quasiment au double
provoque provoque les problèmes que
rencontrent aujourd'hui dans les
problèmes qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui
c'est ma deuxième question il y en a un
qui est particulier je dirais la
médecine générale c'est celui de l'arrêt
de travail on est confronté aujourd'hui
une situation où on a l'impression
parfois de mettre les gens en arrêt de
travail pour rien c'est à dire il sent
qu'à contacter ils sont dans une
situation ne peuvent pas faire de
télétravail et on les met en arrêt de
travail en attendant le test parce que
les délais sont longs donc je pense
qu'il y a là un sujet il ya peut-être
une expertise à faire sur le nombre
d'arrêts de travail mais en tout cas il
ya un vrai
sujet un sujet pour l'entreprise mais un
sujet aussi pour le patient parce que
vous savez monsieur le ministre
au mois de juillet le délai de carence a
été finalement remis en place et
aujourd'hui sur des courts arrêts de
travail
les gens sont en arrêts 3 4 jours en
attendant d'avoir le test et c'est un
vrai sujet financier pour eux tout au
moins pour les pour les petits salaires
donc implore votre attention sur ce
sujet qui est un vrai sujet à la fois
médicale mais aussi sociale le troisième
point il vient peut-être sur la
rétrospective il est peut-être un petit
peu plus agressif mais en tout cas il
nécessite aussi de votre part une
réponse le président de la république
nous a dit dans une très belle
déclaration c'est la guerre sauf que
hier madame la ministre madame busin
madame nice ministre de la santé nous
explique et en fin d'intervention
finalement et de façon un peu impromptue
que santé publique france a failli
notamment sur les stocks et pas
seulement les stocks de masques puisque
on lui a fait re dire ce qu'elles
avaient de façon un peu discrète annoncé
à l'assemblée nationale que sur d'autres
produits
nous avions des défaillances extrême et
qu'il était temps de l'erreur de les
remettre les roms mettre en place donc
la guerre on l'a commencée avec un très
beau char d'assaut qui s'appelle la
santé publique mais il n'a pas été
chargé en au but donc je suppose que si
c'était la guerre le militaire en charge
de mettre les obus dans le char d'assaut
aujourd'hui il serait en tout cas
rechercher identifier pour savoir qui il
est et ce qui s'est passé et aujourd'hui
on aimerait bien savoir si vous avez
mené une enquête interne au sein de
santé publique france pour savoir
finalement où sont les responsabilités
qui sont portées aujourd'hui sur le fait
que dans diverses matières entre autres
les masques et bien sûr aujourd'hui
peut-être les gants et de nombreux
produits pharmaceutiques
il y avait des membres voire des
péremption atteinte depuis depuis
longtemps en voilà monsieur le ministre
merci annie guillemot merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre plusieurs
points le premier point vous avez rendu
hommage et reconnaissance aux soignants
et je crois qu'on est vraiment tous avec
vous bien sûr dans cette reconnaissance
mais pensez vous que le décret que vous
avez pris sur la reconnaissance de la
maladie
professionnel en pensant que les sols
les soignants qui avait été oxygéné
aurait cette reconnaissance soit
vraiment une reconnaissance justement
des soignants est ce que vous allez
rendre un avis positif au conseil de la
sécurité de la santé publique pour le
remplacement éventuel d'un soignant même
s'il est testé qu'ovide asymptomatiques
il devrait rester au travail
il ya eu toute cette polémique
j'aimerais avoir votre avis
le deuxième point alors nous sommes bien
sûr par rapport à vos annonces d'hier
je vais pas revenir sur ce que disait
laurence cohen votre mobilisation et la
mobilisation tout ministère mais souvent
moi je regarde gouffran sco vite parce
que on a besoin de répondre aux
questions et les parlementaires on est
beaucoup beaucoup questionné j'ai eu par
exemple 1,2 ce matin d'appel pour les
piscines est ce que les piscines sont
fermées
est ce que c'est une salle de sport les
taxis aussi qu'ils n'ont pas de masque
souvent dans les taxis parce qu'ils ont
un plexiglas
mais certains n'ont pas de plexi garde
fous ya plein de deux questions comme ça
et aujourd'hui coup franc ce n'est
toujours pas à jour de vos annonces
d'hier on est toujours sur le 17
septembre
et c'est vrai que c'est un aussi un
problème troisième question moi je
reviens sur ce que disait mon collègue
précédent sur la gestion des masques par
santé publique france j'ai eu l'occasion
hier de poser la même question madame
busan la l'étude expertise qui est fait
des débuts 2018
95% des médicaments sont out et sur les
700 millions de masques qu'ils arrêtent
plus de 99 millions l'aide qui part du
directeur de santé publique france au
dgs le dgs lui répond le 30 octobre
alors que la lettre et du 6 septembre je
crois de commander 50 millions de
masques et 50 millions autres si le
budget le permet et tout ça sans avoir
fait référence ou avoir transmis nil où
des gs neale directeur de santé publique
france à la ministre est ce que vous
pensez que c'est normal 95% des
médicaments
donc là il ya un véritable problème et
moi je partage enfin je le redis la
crédibilité de l'état et de
l'organisation de l'état est posée parce
que quand je vois ce que fait l'état en
17 ans de mer sur les mers qui
respectent pas telle ou telle chose
je me demande quand même comment on peut
pas faire une enquête et comment il n'ya
pas des sanctions il ya bien des choses
la crédibilité elle est aussi dans la
reconnaissance qu'ils aient eu pénurie
parce que parce que parce que quatrième
point vous avez dit il faut je vais
gérer la crise aujourd'hui et demain
mais le questionnement entre l'hôpital
privé et l'hôpital public
souvent on nous pose des questions les
citoyens pourquoi l'hôpital privés
n'acceptent pas tous les malades n'ont
que vides ou les c'est la question qu'on
nous pose est pourquoi l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui quelle est votre position
sur cette articulation hôpital privé
hôpital public et par rapport à
l'hôpital public pourquoi on a encore
des médecins qui disent bas aujourd'hui
j'ai encore seize personnes je trouve
pas de place
seize personnes en hospitalisation
d'urgence ne trouvent pas de place est
ce que on est aussi mal préparés que
l'autre fois
enfin la dernière question c'est sur la
question justement de l'organisation
elle-même de l'état la question que j'ai
posée aussi madame busin lors de son
audition à l'assemblée nationale
elle a fait la réflexion nous la refais
hier elle nous l'a détaillé qu'il
faudrait peut-être revoir le système et
créer une agence qui serait une agence
de l'ensemble des pandémies qu'elle soit
sanitaires environnementales ou
accidentels et je voulais avoir aussi
votre avis sur ce sur cette proposition
merci david assouline
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais commencer aussi comme
un collègue cohen par vous dire que ce
qui apparaît au corps dans cette
audition mais on vous a vu depuis le
début de crise vous parlez avec la bonne
foi de celui qui s'est démené et on l'a
vu que vous êtes démener comme personne
pour faire face à une crise forte
inattendu et exceptionnel et c est donc
vous finalement vous vous enfermez dans
cette bonne foi et cette conviction
là nous sommes dans une commission
denquête qui essaye de voir que malgré
tout cette bonne foi il ya eu des
problèmes pour le pouvoir les corriger
et le malaise c'est que vous ne
reconnaissez aucun problème et est par
exemple vous vous entêtez sur quelque
chose qui est maintenant installée pour
tout le monde c'est que il ya eu la
facilité même si vous vous abritez
derrière l'om est ce vous n'avez pas
interroger cette cette question
effectivement validé par l'om est sur la
question des masques grand public parce
que ça vous arrange et parce qu'elle n'y
avait pas de masque et bien qu'en loi
vous avez été chercher même chez un om
est ce le fait que une ministre est venu
nous expliquer que c'était même
dangereux de les porter et que c'était
contre productive c'est l'effet tout le
monde sait que aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de masque qu'on a
expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas et où
sinon peut pas expliquer qu'aujourd'hui
on dise à tout le monde de porter des
masques et que le fait que deux
personnes portent à masquer bien bien
entendu ça réduit les risques dans les
pays asiatiques ça fait bien longtemps
que cette doctrine est installé et qu'on
aurait pu se dire tiens c'est bizarre
l'om est peut-être dit ça mais dans les
pays asiatiques il faut autrement alors
qu'ils sont en proie à ses problèmes
souvent et bien avant nous et donc
pourquoi ils le font vous vous êtes
contenté d'expliquer et ça vous pouvez
le reconnaître parce que le problème
c'est la confiance par rapport à ce que
dit la parole publique pour faire face à
une crise pour l'ensemble des citoyens
et c'est là que je
j'en viens à mes questions actuelles
c'est un peu la même chose quand il ya
un conseil de défense où on nous annonce
que le président va faire des annonces
fortes c'était la semaine dernière et
que finalement seront parce qu'on voit
bien que le virus circule et qu'il faut
réagir fortement
donc on sait qu'il ya une exponentielle
il ya déjà une dizaine de jours et puis
il n'y a pas d' annonce il ya juste la
non ce que les préfets vont agir et vont
prendre des mesures parce qu'il faut les
localiser
et hier on apprend qu'il y à certain
nombre de mesures notamment à marseille
à paris en guadeloupe etc et vous dit on
à concerter bon non non la maire de
paris on l'appelait une heure avant et
elle n'est pas d'accord avec la mesure
elle est d'accord qu'il faut des mesures
je pense qu'à marseille ça doit être le
cas
bien entendu qu'il faut des mesures mais
celles qui sont proposées donc la
concrétisation
c'est là que la concertation doit être
avec avec les élus locaux et se soucie
que ce soit compris en disant les choses
telles quelles et en trouvant les bonnes
mesures
on voit encore quelque chose de décousu
il ya aucune annonce du président on va
dire au préfet donc y voir une
concertation d'une semaine non c'est une
heure avant et on peut se dire par
exemple sur la question des bars les
fermer à 10 heures c'est quand même
atteindre
du point de vue économique une
profession qui est déjà dans une
situation catastrophique on peut se dire
que entre la situation où il suffit d'un
s'asseoir à une terrasse pour ne plus
avoir à porter le masque pour ne plus
avoir à respecter aucune distanciation
sociale et donc des attroupements énorme
dans tous les cafés les restaurants
entre ça et fermé il ya peut-être une
mesure qui est
dire qu'en dehors du moment où on boit
on doit porter le masque y compris sur
la terrasse il ya peut-être ça et
peut-être qu'un élu peuvent vous le dire
si vous l'écoutez avant d'annoncer donc
la concertation encore une fois dans une
certaine panique d'une situation qui est
en train de monter eh bien elle est
juste réduit à eux pas grand chose
en gros je veux conclure par une
question mais qui a aussi un conseil je
pense même dans les crises de ce type
que dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
telles qu'elles se pousse à vous qui
devait prendre des décisions au français
est plus productif pour entraîner la
nation affronter une telle crise que
tout les les choses qu'on cache un peu
c'est clair que vous êtes confrontés
aujourd'hui à la question suivante il y
à un virus qui circule de façon
exponentielle ça ressemble à ce qui se
passait au mois de mars la mesure que
vous avez pris alors été radicale le
confinement
vous savez que vous ne pouvez pas le
faire comme ça aujourd'hui sans mettre à
bas l'économie vous le dire aux français
donc il ya des activités économiques on
va prendre un peu plus de risques
on va aller travailler on va prendre des
transports on va laisser les écoles
ouvertes pour que les gens puissent
aller travailler dit luc c'est pour ça
que vous re confiné pas mais quand il
s'agit de s'amuser de paître dans
l'activité économique allait au bar etc
là on fait n'importe quoi vous vous
tapez et ça les français le sentent
qu'il ya de l'incohérence dit les choses
et vous assisterez la nation merci
la dernière question marie pierre de la
gontrie
merci monsieur le président vous l'avez
compris cette commission denquête veut
aussi identifier les points qui
permettrait sans doute en étant amélioré
de de mieux préparer l'appareil d'état
et l'appareil sanitaire à d'éventuelles
difficultés il se trouve d'ailleurs que
les difficultés nous les vivons
aujourd'hui donc je je voudrais vous
interroger sur les relations de l'état
et donc évidemment les vôtres mais pas
que avec les ars
nous avons auditionné car vous avez sans
doute vu que le choix de cette
commission a été de d'entendre d'abord
les acteurs qu'on peut qualifier guimet
de terrain avant de 2,2 par les hauts
responsables d'entendre des responsables
nationaux
nous avons entendu les directeurs des
directeurs des ars et ceux dont ce qu'il
est ressorti de ces auditions je vais
pas vous égrainé nous n'avons plus le
temps il est tard c'est que de
nombreuses alertes avaient été remontés
je prends bien la période à partir de
laquelle vous êtes ministre de
nombreuses alertes avaient été avait été
adressée auprès du ministère donc leur
interlocuteur naturel étant le directeur
général de la santé et certains ars
ayant constaté que leur signalement
était sans réponse d'autant qu' il y
avait je me trompe peut-être mais une
réunion téléphonique tous les soirs et
que lors de cette réunion téléphonique
tous les aeros étaient présents et que
donc il n'y avait pas de possibilité de
d'appréhension différenciée selon les
territoires
donc sur ce point là est-ce que sans
aller jusqu à vous suggérer
d'autocritique ce n'est pas du tout
l'objet mais est-ce que vous avez bien
identifier des pistes d'amélioration
dans la façon dont vous avez pu
travailler avec les ars notamment en
l'illustrant avec la question des
transferts
on a déjà eu l'occasion ici d'évoquer
les transferts de malades qui ont pu
être effectués en france ou à l'étranger
et un rs nous à nous a relaté un
incident qui s'est produit le 6 avril
concernant le transfert de patient en
autriche ou alors que
l'avion était d'ores et déjà présent je
résume
sur instruction du cabinet du ministre
il avait été décidé d'arrêter le
transfert et que est en poupe soumis au
pouvoir hiérarchique
ces instructions étaient appliquées sans
que l'on sache c'est la santé des
patients pouvaient être mis en danger
par cette décision alors vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous avez noté cette
phrase vous avez dit je ne crois pas que
les ars soit complètement abruti c'était
une façon un peu informel j'ai bien
compris j'ai bien compris
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
vous avez évoqué par cette formule le
fait que vous considériez qu'ils avaient
une réelle compétence
donc comment expliquez-vous que votre
cabinet à ce moment-là et décidé de
stopper un transfert alors même que les
malades étaient aux plaies au pied au
pied de l'avion
enfin dernière chose on en parle peu
mais la situation dans les universités
se dégrade de manière considérable quels
sont les instructions précises enfin je
dirais efficace que vous avez adressé
vous ou le gouvernement mais bon dans ce
domaine et enfin je pense que votre
mémoire vous fait des tours parce que
j'ai retrouvé un propos vous avez pu
tenir vous même sur les masques sur les
stocks de ffp2 lors d'une conférence de
presse en février où vous avez indiqué
nous disposons de stock de stocks
stratégiques de les hôpitaux dans un
très grand nombre de cabinets libéraux
et dans un grand nombre de services de
l'état qui nous permettent de faire face
à la demande il n'y a donc aucun
problème d'accès à ces masques pour
toutes celles et ceux qui en ont besoin
donc c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
faut être très attentif à tous ces
propos qui ont été tenus merci monsieur
le président mr sylla et cloutés c'était
la dernière question donc nous vous
écoutons pour vos dernières réponses
j'ai peut-être démarré par la fin a
commencé par répondre à la sénatrice
marie pierre de la gontrie
parce que j'ai été très attentif au
travail des agences régionales de santé
et parce que comme vous l'avez souligné
nous avons eu des discussions quasi
quotidiennes avec l'ensemble des agences
j'ai pu m'assurer du travail qui était
effectué par les unes et les autres dans
les différentes situations qui étaient
rencontrés
vous avez auditionné parmi ceux que vous
avez auditionné un directeur général de
l'agencé régionale de santé qui a été
démis en conseil des ministres de ses
fonctions qui a fait une saisine
d'ailleurs de la justice pour contester
les conditions de sa démission
c'est du fait qu'il soit démis de ses
fonctions motrices 6e directeur général
a été démis de ses fonctions c'est parce
que justement j'ai été attentif à la
situation de l'action de chaque
direction d'aaer s dans chaque
territoire concerné et que certes le
grand est et est la région qui a été le
plus percuté et le plus tôt par la crise
épidémique mais je vous invite à
consulter l'ensemble des élus quel que
soit le bord politique de la région vous
verrez que lorsque je me suis entretenu
avec les élus il n'y avait un consensus
sur les dysfonctionnements hélas hélas
sur les dysfonctionnements et donc ne
pas à considérer pardonnez moi que ce
directeur d'agencé agents de santé dans
le constat qui fait de l'action que nous
avons menée l'emportent sur l'ensemble
des autres directeurs plus
d'administrations centrales plus mes
services ministériels et moi même
c'était pas l'autriche madame la
sénatrice était la république tchèque
il y avait des transferts des
évacuations sanitaires
six patients qui était anticipé pour la
république tchèque
compte tenu de la saturation vous savez
à ce jour à cette période là j'étais
appelé à peu près plusieurs fois par
jour en tout cas par des élus de la
région grand test des maires présidents
de départements ou des directions
d'établissement qui me suppliait qui me
demandait légitimement d'activer tous
les réseaux d'évacuation sanitaire qu'on
pouvait évacuer parce qu'il sentait la
pression la bague monthey et qu'ils
avaient légitimement très peur tous
bords politiques confondus
je crois que j'étais à peu près tous eu
la république tchèque était une
destination éloigné pour des malades et
le jour où le transfert était organisée
la vague épidémique avait commencé à
baisser de façon sensible le nombre de
patients admis dans les rénovations de
la région avaient commencé depuis
quelques temps à refluer et j'ai été
contacté par les équipes sur place me
disant qu'il trouvait aberrant d'aller
but est d'envoyer par hélicoptère des
patients en république tchèque où il se
réveillera un jour hors du commun
très loin de chez eux très loin de leurs
familles alors même qu'il y avait
désormais des places vacantes dans les
hôpitaux environnants même assez
tu ris je suis certain je suis même sûr
qu'à ma place vous auriez pris
exactement la même décision qui
consistait à annuler le transfert
sanitaire abjean suis sûr j'en suis sûr
tout le monde ici prendre la même
décision que cette décision soit
contestée par le directeur me confortent
dans la décision qui a pu être prises
hélas nous séparer d'un directeur en
pleine crise ce qui était pas une
décision facile
sur la question les universités pardon
je suis sous serment je ne suis pas je
ne peux pas sortir de mes compétences
sanitaires et parce que vous avez
insisté sur la nécessité d'avoir une
communication gouvernementale
harmonieuse je préfère renvoyer à la
ministre en charge des universités les
questions évidemment et des protocoles
sanitaires qui sont qui existent au
niveau national qui sont très claires
dont l'application territoriale par
certains rectorats peut-être
éventuellement renforcée et dont
l'application territoriale par certaines
écoles ou universités peut être encore
renforcée bon tout ça nécessite
l'expertisé de la ministre en charge sur
les des chiffres technique pour les
tests très rapide très rapidement sur
les chiffres des sur les chiffres des
tests capacité pcr fin février début
mars 2000 à 2500 test par jour début
avril cinq mille tests par jour au
moment du des confirmands au 11 mai
entre quarante et cinquante mille tests
par jour avec une capacité qui a été
estimé qu'ils étaient calculés enfin de
confinement sur la base d'un air
inférieur à 1 où il y aurait chaque pour
chaque cas positifs dix à quinze cas
contacts et donc nous avions défini
qu'il fallait que nous soyons en mesure
d'atteindre si nécessaire les 700000 la
grande donne est différente au moment du
décompte final
c'est que au lieu de 10 à 15 la
contacter si vous avez entre 2 et 4 cas
contacts par patient positif et donc ça
ça a changé
ça a changé la donne sur désormais nous
sommes capables d'en faire 1,3 million
et on sera sans doute capable d'en faire
davantage si nécessaire à l'avenir sur
les tests de thé travail le sujet des
carences vous avez raison c'est un sujet
qui est extrêmement qui est extrêmement
compliqué parce que selon la situation
si vous n'êtes qu'à contacter ou si vous
êtes positif seulement la personne
qu'ils avaient
vous êtes en activité partielle où vous
êtes en arrêt de travail avec indemnités
journalières et j'aurai des ternes ans
en fonction des situations dans
lesquelles vous vous trouvez et sa
déstructuration ans maladie les ars et
c'est le savent les médecins y compris
sur le sujet télétravail doit être
encouragée de toute façon à chaque fois
qu'on peut le faire à chaque fois qu'on
est encore plus encore quand on est dans
une zone où le virus circule beaucoup le
rôle de sps dans la crise j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure enfin mon rôle n'est pas
de tirer à l'armé lourde pour reprendre
votre métaphore guerrière sur une agence
qui composait de personnes d'experts qui
font de leur mieux depuis le début de la
crise et qui se sont organisés depuis le
début de la crise ça veut pas dire et
pour rebondir sur le fait qu'il y aurait
pas de critiques ou d'auto critique ou
qu'on n'est pas capable de pointes et
nous mêmes le doigt sur des lenteurs sur
des inerties j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
de la mauvaise publication des chiffres
des tests qui m'a assez énervé pendant
un moment parce que je compliqué quand
on vous reproche de pas faire de test
parce que les chiffres que vous sentez
vous mêmes sont en dessous de la réalité
bref vous imaginez bien je vous ai parlé
découvrions qui sont emblématiques d'un
certain nombre de lenteur qui sont pas
forcément le lier à santé publique
france d'ailleurs mais qui ont pu
émailler cette gestion de crise
nous reverrons tout cela a posteriori
encore une fois moi je suis au milieu
d'une bataille et moi j'ai besoin des
troupes et j'ai besoin que les troupes
soient mobilisés j'ai besoin que les
agences soit totalement mobilisée
qu'elle soit motivée et moi à chaque
fois que j'enregistre des
dysfonctionnements ou des choses qui ne
vont pas je n'accuse pas encore moins
publiquement j'y vais et je suis allé à
santé publie france avec des visites qui
était plus ou moins organisés pour
pouvoir rencontrer tout le monde saisir
les sujets quand il se posait c'est
comme ça que j'envisage le management en
période de crise sur les soignants
qu'ils soient qu'à contacter ou ou
asymptomatiques
eh bien ils doivent être exclues du
travail pendant la même période que les
autres on avait envisagé qu'il pourrait
revenir au travail
masqué si tout le système sanitaire
était saturé et que c'était une question
entre guillemets pardonnez moi pour les
malades de vie ou de mort mais sinon
évidemment qu'ils sont logés à la même
enseigne que les autres
la déclinaison des mesures annoncées
hier je ne vais pas rentrer dans le
détail parce que comme je les ai annoncé
hier et comme justement on me reprochait
de ne
on m'aurait encore plus reprocher sur
l'aï pas fait le c'est le préfet qui tu
en train de concerter les élus dans les
différents territoires et qui devra
ensuite affiner les différentes mesures
sur les horaires les modalités
d'applications etc etc sur tout ce qui
concerne la période antérieure au 16
février pardonnez moi mais parce que je
suis sous serment je ne le commenterai
pas je n'ai pas en connaître avec
suffisamment de précision
de fait et d'assurance pour le risque et
sous serment à émettre un avis personnel
non seulement mon avis n'est pas très
intéressant et par ailleurs vous avez
auditionné la ministre et les ministres
en charge
à cette époque sur l'articulation
hospitalières publiques river j'ai
abondamment répondu puis enfin pour
monsieur assouline chez assouline seul
sénateur agences de crise par des
agences de création de crise questions
précises de l'adam association agents au
christ et son numéro est ce que ce
serait utile de créer une agence de
crise spécifique mais j'ai répondu tout
à l'heure j'ai dit que quand on a
fusionné les plus avec l'inpes et c'est
probablement qu'il faut revoir cette
déclinaison l'arrêt de toute façon ça
fait notre pays va devoir s'armer contre
ddt et d'autres types de crises qui sont
pas forcément des crises épidémique mais
qui vont à des crises qui vont avoir
trait à la santé environnementale
il faut qu'on puisse armer dans les
territoires dans les régions en face de
la l'information de la formation de
l'intervention et donc on va revoir ce
dispositif est avec vous avec vous fort
de votre expérience
je voudrais terminer un répondre à
monsieur assouline est à souligner je
vous cite tout le monde sait que les
français le centre on nous avait annoncé
des mesures fortes
sa solide moi je ne fais jamais je dis
que je ne venais pas ici avec ni des
opinions d'une idée on dit je ne peux
pas me le permettre je suis ministre en
charge de la crise je ne raisonne et je
ne décide qu'à partir des faits je ne
sais pas qui vous annoncer que y aurait
des mesures fortes au précédent conseil
de défense et sécurité nationale moi
j'en ai vécu plus de 30 il y en a eu
avec des annonces fortes
on a eu qui étaient là pour faire le
point des objectifs etc
lorsque vous dites tout le monde le sait
très bien que les masques vous me
demandez de faire un parjure
le sénateur dans la mesure où je vous ai
répondu en vous disant qu'ils n'avaient
pas de lien entre la doctrine des
masques et la gestion de la pénurie et
que vous dites tout le monde le sait
avec vous mentez vous me demandez où
fait le constat n'a pas revu roeckel cas
ça vous engage ou vous me demandez en
ferrain
vous répondrais non et je vous ai
répondu sur le fond les dès lé départ
les ennemis les élus qui dénoncent le
manque de concertation
c'est pas le manque de concertation qui
dénonce à travers sa faim ne soyons pas
dupes
c'est la nature des mesures à chaque
fois qu'un élu m'a dit je ne je n'ai pas
été concertés sur cette mesure quand il
est d'accord ça pose pas de difficulté
donc que les élus qui dénoncent le
manque de concertation dénonce les
mesures que les élus disent publiquement
je considère bien sûr mais il d'ailleurs
ils le font donc concentrons nous sur le
fond des mesures et pas sur la forme de
mesures est bien maîtrisée concentrons
nous sur le fond vous pouvez passer deux
semaines à consulter les uns et les
autres sur une mesure si vous ne tombez
pas d'accord à la fin il ya ceux qui
diront j'ai consulté concertée je décide
parce que gouverner c'est choisir est je
protège et il ya les autres qui diront
on n'a pas été consultée concertée
puisqu'on n'a pas gagné mais attendez
mais mais je vous ai donné l'exemple
marseillais et les deux heures passées à
la préfecture et les semaines et les
semaines passent et a alerté à
sensibiliser en disant attention
attention donc
pardonnez moi mais ils ont le droit de
contester des mesures et le couple et
ils ont parfaitement le droit de
contester des mesures nous sommes en
droit de les demander dans la maintenant
dans la mesure où justement elle montre
que elles réduisent l'épidémie les
études qui montrent qu' il ya quatre
fois plus de risque d'être contaminé au
co vide quand on a fréquenté un bar dans
les jours avant que quand on n'a pas
fréquenté de bar je n'y peux rien et je
fréquente
enfin je fréquentais quand j'avais le
temps les bars et les restaurants et
s'il s'agit pas d'incriminer qui que ce
soit c'est un c'est un fait qui est
complexe c'est un fait qui est complexe
et qui participe de la diffusion de
l'épidémie
là enfin pour monsieur assouline la loi
prévoit que la police sanitaire est une
compétence de l'état
premier ministre
mss ministre et solidarité de la santé
préfet c'est le choix du premier
ministre et de choix du gouvernement
donc voilà je peux le dire j'entends
j'entends parfaitement les critiques
j'entends parfaitement les remises en
question j'entends parfaitement qu'un
maire ait envie de défendre la vie
sociale dans sa commune les bars et les
restaurants
j'entends aussi les maires qui tout en
défendant la vie sociale et la vie
économique dans leur commune me disent
c'est la bonne décision à prendre
aujourd'hui pour protéger les habitants
parce que ça se passe mal au niveau de
la diffusion épidémique
donc vous avez des mères c'est pas une
question politique puisque je vous ai
cité un certain nombre de maires issus
du même parti que la maire de marseille
aux clameurs de paris qui considère que
toute mesure nécessaire dès lors qu'elle
est justifiée elle n'est pas à discuter
donc je ne dis pas que c'est pas dur et
je me mets à la place des marseillais et
je sais qu'il ya des gens qui sont en
colère je fais comme vous sur les
réseaux sociaux
je n'y vais plus parce que surtout après
les soirées comme celle ci n'est pas
masochiste mais honnêtement tout ce qui
est fait est fait pour pouvoir assurer
la protection des gens et si on voit que
la situation sanitaire s'améliore nous
l'avons déjà fait rire personne n'a
critiqué en mayenne au mois de juillet
quand il fait une reprise épidémique et
qu'on a mis en place des mesures de
restriction de rassemblement qu'on a mis
des mesures de couvre feu personne n'a
critiqué ce qui a été fait en mayenne et
vous pouvez me rappeler ce qui s'est
passé en mayenne en mayenne d'épidémie à
la fiche lac et l'impact sanitaire il a
été extrêmement faible et j'y suis allé
et en guyane
pareil les mesures de couvre-feu les
mesures de gestion quand ça a commencé à
flamber et on a réussi à enrayer
l'épidémie
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on ne puisse
pas le faire à marseille comme sur tout
autre territoire de la république
encore une fois c'est le seul objectif
qui est le nôtre c'est protéger la santé
des français
non mais j'ai le débat mais un point
qu'on souhaitait aborder avec vous mais
ça va être très long et c'est pas
c'était le problème de vaccination
antigrippale vous allez la rendre
obligatoire sur l'aveu de sa vaccination
antigrippale parce que c'est parce que
ce cumul est avec avec le co vide
c'est tellement c'est une question tout
à fait essentiel merci catherine
effectivement se les poser moi c'était
c'était une précision pour qu'il ait pas
de malentendu quand je suis sur les
mesures et je demandais de la cohérence
comment expliquez-vous par exemple ces
voix là c'est une question qu'un
français pourrait vous poser là puisque
je les ai vus comme ça poser brutalement
éjectée pas capable de répondre dans les
mesures prises l'activité sportive est
interdite
on ne doit pas être très importante pour
l'économie donc une dame dit ma fille
qui fait de la danse dans une grande
salle où il ya dix mots mme s passée de
suffisamment n'a plus le droit de faire
la danse par contre elle peut aller en
classe où ils sont trente entassés dans
la classe qu'est-ce que je réponde
qu'est-ce que vous remercie agnès
préville un gel angèle
mais merci monsieur le président moi
j'ai pas eue et la réponse et je ne
doute pas de la bonne volonté
je vous ai demandé au moment où on met
en isolement les ehpad est ce qu'il y a
eu dans les consignes le fait qu'un
livreur même devait être protégée et que
non seulement les soignants mais
également tout le reste du personnel
devaient avoir des équipements de
protection
c'était mal ationnaire si monsieur le
ministre trois réponses courtes un
madame pardon si j'ai mal répondu à
votre question non seulement ils
devaient procéder mais ils pouvaient pas
rentrer donc merci pose pas deuxième
question pourquoi salle de sport je suis
mis la santé je crois sincèrement son
bien-être du sport aux bienfaits du
sport sur la santé c'est serait à
nouveau
hélas dans les salles de sport il ya de
la transpiration il ya des jets de
gouttelettes et les mouvements et il ya
des contaminations qui se font beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus dans certains
contextes que dans d'autres et notamment
que dans le milieu professionnel où la
distanciation le masquer l'absence de
transpiration joue assis chez assouline
par contre vous poser une question
gelée d'hier soir ça peut être pas été
perçues dans le flot de d'annonce mais
s'agissant d'un gymnase et des salles de
sport je n'ai pas dit que les gymnases
serait interdite pour les enfants en
scolaire par exemple j'ai dit que tout
cela fait partie des mesures discutées
en concertation entre les préfets les
élus
donc dans les zones qui sont concernés
dans les zones qui dans les zones qui
sont cantonnés les salles de sport les
salles de sport les gars les salles de
sport clairement pour qui concerne les
adultes avec parfois une forte
concentration de personnes dans une même
pièce avec de la transpiration des
gouttelettes quitté pose là on sait que
c'est hélas encore une fois pas bon mais
vous avez des gymnases qui sont
accessibles aux enfants dans le domaine
scolaire qui peuvent éventuellement être
amené donc voyez jeu quand on parle de
concertation en fait elle existe plus
que j'ai pas la réponse à la question
que vous posez selon territoires
concernés
et selon l'issue de la concertation
c'est un point qui pourtant est enfin
c'était sur la grippe
beaucoup de questions sur la grippe et
je m'en réjouis
la campagne anti grippal elle commence
le 13 octobre comme chaque année elle
commencera pas avant puisque si on
vaccine trop tôt le vaccin perd en
efficacité dans la durée et donc il ne
protégerait pas au bon moment par
ailleurs nous avons déjà les conclusions
de l'épisode grippale dans l'hémisphère
sud qui montre que la grippe a était un
retardé donc habituellement elle
intervient en outre en france à partir
du 20 décembre
il ya des raisons de penser qu'elle
interviendra encore plus tard de l a été
faible masque gestes barrières surtout
gestes-barrières d'ailleurs ce que le
masque
les études montrent que ça marche pas
trop dessus mais vous avez le masque
vous avez les gestes barrière la
distanciation sociale et l'attention
qu'ils portent et la mécanique peut-être
de compétition entre la grippe locaux
vides qui utilise un récepteur un peu
similaire pour rentrer donc
néanmoins nous devons faire extrêmement
attention à la vaccination des publics
vulnérables et des soignants dans notre
pays
c'est une c'est une cible qui est
importante et donc la campagne vaccinale
nous nous mettrons évidemment l'accent
sur le sujet pour la première fois en
plus des commandes des officines nous
avons procédé à des sécurisations de
commandes d'état et nous avons 30% de
doses de vaccin en plus que les années
précédentes
30% et il se serait un vrai enjeu que la
vaccination des soignants
je prends un retour de retour sur la
réunion me semble-t-il que les soignants
en ehpad on a pas dépassé les 30% de
couverture vaccinale antigrippal donc ça
c'est un vrai sujet l'obligation
repasserait je pense par la loi monsieur
le sénateur je ne suis même pas sûr que
si nous voulions faire nous aurions le
temps dans les délais impartis
dans les pas d'un parti de faire en tout
cas c'est nous allons avoir une
stratégie affinée en matière de
vaccination antigrippale qui passe par
la haute autorité de santé et nous
tenons prêts catherine des roches non il
faudra bien se poser la question de
l'obligation dé soigner on en parle
depuis des années il faut une vraie
volonté c'est l'exemple monsieur le
ministre qu'il faudrait donner à travers
la grille pour que nous constituer un
comprendre l'intérêt de vaccination
demain on l'espère à travers le coc vide
c'est pour ça que nous sommes fort
intéressé avec cette campagne de
vaccination merci en tout cas de votre
patience mes chers commissaire mais si
monsieur le ministre pouvait réponse
donc je clos la séance